welcome everybody it's the Street
podcast Friday after dark let's go
we're up
actually we have a fun episode today for
a change wow you know we had a week of
pretty heavy shows and today we're
bringing it to a raw light and fun fun
times nice
of the raw that's right we brought uh a
really fun segment together where
I posed in my
most exposed and sexual
um
a French girl style that's accessible to
me here let me pull it up and not really
sexual I'm kidding by that just to be
clear and um thanks and uh the crew all
drew me so this is kind of like a part
two of the bust
okay yeah which was a fantastic and
iconic some may even say episode and
um so so I'm gonna gaze into the psyche
of each individual artist and try to
guess who painted what
and eel is actually going to be painting
one
yeah I uh I heard about the segment last
night and I was like can I try one so I
want to do it during the show he sent it
to you this was the pose I tried to do
the rows from Titanic pose here I'll
open it for you guys
I was trying to think about a mix of
pleasure right oh no
what of the pleasure and the pain yeah
and I began there she is
beautiful just like Rose from Titanic
fantastic modeling it's a direct
reference
um
if you didn't know oh we got another one
you got another angle you want to open
that one
yeah
I'm giving it away for free today
everybody that's right
although you got to pay extra if you
want me to take my socks off
[Laughter]
so that'll be fun looking forward to
that
um also huge news in the H3 uh World
Jimmy Lee the collaboration that was
promised by the gods that was
prophesized
and the Dead Sea Scrolls
mm-hmm took place yesterday
the Jersey Outlaw was invited on a
recorded episode of Howie Mandel does
how about that which is just I cannot
wait
who watched this a million followers and
on Howie Mandel yeah and on here what a
week what a week for Jim and he met
Martin and he met Martin that's right
yeah what a week forever he's blowing up
he is kind of you know I'm so excited I
can't and I as soon as it
first of all somehow Jimmy was able to
get in there the next day yeah
and he was feeling pretty anxious about
it because you know how he's a legit
celebrity
so he's like when should I call him do
you think should I call him tonight
should I call him tomorrow I was like
wait till tomorrow Jimmy give it it was
like 5 30. I was like calm during the
working hours
and uh
apparently called him at 8am because he
got his ass in that studio somehow
that same day it's amazing and first of
all shout out to Howie Mandel who's yeah
he's the best isn't he and then
um shout out to Jimmy too because look
at the hustle you know yeah yo what's
your excuse he's like 70 years old
like the world's oldest Make-a-Wish talk
about like jumping an opportunity you
know he's like he really did he did I
spoke I spoke with him on the phone uh
last night he was very appreciative and
he was almost tears in his eyes
um he was just so thankful for you Ethan
for setting that up and he was just he
was thrilled well absolutely I'm happy
for I truly am happy for him and I I
genuinely do look forward to watching
that episode yeah as soon as I saw that
I messaged Howie I was like how'd it go
he said and I'll quote him
because I don't want to misquote on
something this important he said semen
and I quote
amazing what a character
that is for sure I mean that's true
that's true and then we asked uh we
asked Jimmy how it went and he said
amazing also okay what there was one uh
small thing that concerned me although
how we didn't uh bring it up and he
seemed pretty happy overall but in one
of these pictures he posted
um he looks like really close to
touching him and that got us all a
little concerned because I wouldn't want
to do that to how he I should have told
him beforehand like I was gonna ask did
you guys warn him no hold it but I feel
like he probably knows he's like so into
culture well let me show you this photo
celebrity culture where is that photo in
here
yeah
or just link it because he's you can see
how he's leaning away from him and
Jimmy's leaning into it and their hands
it looks like are touching like this oh
Jimmy does he's very like he wants to be
affectionate he's a close talker yeah
oh boy so here they are
how he's leaning away quite clearly
Jimmy's leaning in but are there hands I
mean I see contact
it's hard to tell but it looks like
they're touching
but I do think like Howie because nobody
ever talked to me about that on how he's
set and I guess he's just too nice of a
guy to make his his guess feel uncommon
maybe he doesn't want to make a big deal
out of it but if I was him I'd probably
be like hey just so you know he's got
this thing so just try not to touch him
right yeah baseball thing's cool he
seems to be cool with that um
but it's his Rodeo yeah
he knows what he's doing exactly he
knows what he's doing so um so this
happened and it seemed like it was a
really wholesome good thing so I
couldn't be happier with this and I mean
how he's such a legend for that isn't he
for bringing them I mean come on so
surprised to hear about the unpaid
interns because really yeah because
remember when we were like oh my God it
has such a huge team now how many people
is he paying like none of them how is he
affording all this stuff well there's
even another wrinkle to it that I didn't
say these are all our fans
right these aren't like people he found
on like a job Forum that are like
looking for a leg up in the history
these are our fans that are working for
free for him
so you know it's like toss him a 20 man
you know don't tell me that your
Dentistry office is on the downturn come
on Jimmy you're fine you're doing great
but let's look at how I was surprised by
that
uh let's take a look here
Oh Yeah from JoJo to uh
better than that and by the way the live
that we did together was his last and
only live so yeah the grand experiment
it was didn't work out it takes time to
figure that stuff out I mean yes it did
yield some uh great moments but I don't
it's it's a it's a it's kind of a big
undertaking yeah but um
Jojo
let's get I mean his his diversity of
guests is pretty on there so yeah
you know Joe Joe
bill wait bill was on a month ago we got
a tank that episode
oh man he he really got good views too
that's gonna be a problem let's look at
the top of all time dude
I wonder if he knows Jay Shetty
I do wonder that right I feel like
probably yes wait if he has Jay Shetty
on and it doesn't get views then you win
podcasts of the year but the conspiracy
is confirmed that he's a nobody by the
way I want to also have a little bit of
a complaint when I go to popular it
doesn't show the live that I did because
I would be twice on the top list can I
take that to YouTube with all these tabs
that they created
live look how many times I don't get all
the time
like way too many oh why does it lie I
know you have Community separate how
many how many times you click this in
your career in your life only when I'm
trying really hard to find your your
life at home that you do yeah
so but so and then be about the only
time I click this when I'm trying to
find out Twitter or Instagram link right
so there's a better way to do that
channels I mean what year is this we
don't even do this anymore who
cares channels shut up what year
Community playlist nobody uses playlist
go back to the channels
you know yeah
yo he's using the prolapse picture what
Eclipse channel it's pretty fun oh my
God that's my Twitter
um Banner
dude what a king man you can't beat
Howie he is oh my God amazing today it's
crazy now that I watch Vanderpump to see
Tom is number one I know
so now that you once you're caught up on
Manor pump you gotta go watch that
interview oh it's that guy yes yes he's
the uh by the way
because
yeah Howie doesn't know anything he
doesn't know about the whole situation
he did zero prep give him about the uh
the Scandal
anything and it's like it's like yeah
tell me what's the show about yes
basically right Poor Tom tell us your
side of the story like nobody wants to
hear that I want to watch I'm just
afraid to spoil it so Tom's a d no no no
don't do it yeah it was some it'll spot
by the way I love how they edited though
in the thumbnail he looks like a leper
or something Tom
like his skin is boiling off him because
he's like a handsome guy that's like his
whole identity obsessed with himself but
here he just looks like a grainy weird
looks like he's had his and not that
they look weird but I'm just gonna say
it it looks like he has a skin graft
so whoever did the thumbnail did a good
job on that
boy's daughter
she had to get in
this because she was the one who knew
everything yeah but how he was like
running the conversation so
yo this what flavors is cream Lena
all different flavors vanilla latte that
is
good so good I know that's my favorite
people are thinking I was going to say
busting but I did it
but pretty good it sounded like Theodore
for a moment I was like are you doing a
tuner thing before we take coffee
so can I talk about my shirt yeah please
do please do
Sam created this masterpiece thank you
so good I love it so much honestly you
guys are gonna need to see it up close
because there's beautiful detail there's
a there's a beating on the back
it says All Dogs Go to Heaven I love
this design so much Sam I was like this
is like a really good design for like a
tattoo fresh shirt that's amazing
thank you so much it's really cool and I
love all the
because this is right up our I feel
right up our alley with the rhinestones
and then the embroidery on the back is
really cool yeah I love it
thanks I had fun making it
I love it so much
well you excited for my tattoo by the
way did you comment on that
did I comment like what just about the
tattoo when you were talking about it oh
yeah yeah sorry my memory is just kind
of
I don't remember specific events at all
just kind of happens
I support your decision because of the
meaning
I was a little hesitant at first because
you don't have other tattoos and so it's
going to be like just one and you don't
plan on getting other ones you won't see
it though like 95 of the time you don't
even see it it's just for me I'm not
trying to look cool or be a tat guy
you know what I mean
but I think it would be nice to see it
all the time yeah I think so too
we put up a really nice
uh I don't it's just a wall of a bunch
of
Shredder photos we put it up yesterday
and it's really nice yeah that's our bed
so we get to see it behind all the time
oh somebody posted a photo okay here it
is
honestly I couldn't even decide it was
so hard I printed so many photos
and now I have like a million photos of
Shredder so I'm gonna I think I'm gonna
also do a photo album
um
here the photos are so precious like him
with the kids one he has so many good
photos like so hard to probably you guys
haven't even seen these like him in the
crib with Daddy when he was super young
and he's just so sweet here he is with
Brucie kissing him and here he is
playing with Teddy in the bed he's so
good the kids love the dog beds yeah
here he is standing on the Walker The
Walker looking for scraps yeah
who knows and then the bottom one just
sitting like the prince that he is yeah
I love that photo
I can't believe he's gone some days most
days it's just so weird yeah
yeah it's been hard it's like you
you're supposed to just move on but
it's not
she's a huge loss still taking time to
process
he's been literally by our side
everywhere every moment for the past
yeah five six years you know it really
was like a therapy dog in a lot of ways
like even though you would also drive us
crazy
so on the one hand not so therapy but at
the end of the day whenever I watch TV
would be cuddling with me and that's
like the the best moment
right he knew he knew when you needed
him
anyway don't need to get all sappy right
now been there already
but here we go Ashton my boy Ashton
Kutcher the suspected murderer
actually I'll say this I don't think he
was just I don't think he's actually
suspected he was not suspect yeah I
think it's pretty was pretty clearly
that other guy yeah
because it wasn't one murder too right
it was a few right he was a serial
killer apparently I know this is
gruesome but she was stabbed like 50
times oh God like really gruesome
that's awful murderer it is awful
yeah but Ashton as resigns from his
anti-sex oh anti-child sex abuse
org after backlash from Danny Masterson
oh my God I'm coming out as pro-child
sex wait can Danny now write a letter of
character about Ashton yes that would
that might be impactful for him wow I
think Ashton needs help right now you
know that's my best friend I think that
Danny master
that would also sway things he was on
That 70s Show huge show yeah so famous
yeah it was a famous actor could use a
little letter here
you know uh God he's got to be feeling
like such a yeah right now
yeah and he is man did you know he's of
Angel uh investor in Uber I did because
I watched Shark Tank
I think very good you've said it like 50
times
he's really he's so much more than an
actor Dave listen he's a shark he's a
guy with money he's also a money man
he's an angel investor what an Angel by
the way can you think of a more self
congrat congratulatory title I'm an
angel investor I always wonder what's
with the angel you have money
why are you an angel I don't know that
maybe let's find out why it's called
that but I know the angel investor is
someone who comes before no yeah I know
because they're like I'm an angel do you
understand what I'm doing are you
interesting it actually it originated in
is it really that way somebody saved me
no the rich people patting themselves on
the back what application of the term
angel originates in Broadway Theater
where it was used to describe wealthy
individuals who provided money for
theatrical Productions that would
otherwise have to had shut down yep
itself
at least that is like supporting the
Arts is basically a charitable acts for
the goodness of it's basically in that
context it's another term for being like
a patron yeah an actual Patron but in
that in that case it makes more sense
because you're doing something for the
public good here he's just doing it to
make a bunch of money for himself
investing your money in something that's
going angel investor how about how about
you be an angel investor you're dead
girlfriend I think generally when
something somebody's deemed an angel
investor it's because the Investments
are considered pretty risky
so what because most Silicon Valley like
startup companies fail right like the
majority of them yeah but for these rich
it's a buck shot they know
that right right it's all again you're
right it's a money game definitely to
make money so yeah it's a money game
money it's I'm a God investor yeah god
tier
you know I like to come in even before
the angel investors
even like when you're just starting to
realize you might have an idea I come in
like God let there be light and create
your whole world yeah let there be more
investment
anyway
shout out to uh Ashton for uh
really just a great fantastic career
imagine that at Wells Fargo they'll be
like we have a new savings account the
Angelic savings account yeah it's really
great it has a .02 uh uh return yeah
it's a huge leap on our previous
Jesus signed it off himself damn isn't
Jesus is endorsing the saving account
God damn this coffee is good
right is it really that good people in
the chat are pointing out that our
members are our Angel Investors that's
true and that actually is that makes
your literal Divinity and your literal
Divinity but they are but that's true
because nobody there you go that does
make sense because they're doing
something that doesn't benefit well
there are bonuses right that come with
it there are great benefits don't get me
wrong like watching you docs ourselves
every week exclusive members
um videos on every Tuesday that's a huge
benefit your likes to live chat you're
like angel investor and Jimmy right
that's true I'll take that actually
right we've been there from day one
I'll accept that
I'm an angel investor of sorts sad of me
but you guys support the show not for
your own self-interest you do it because
you are an angel
and you are a warrior on the battlefield
of God first light and dark
and you've chosen the path of life
to support us in the valley of Shadow
the armor of God the weapon the staff of
God into him from behind that's right
and when we walk through the valley of
the shadow of death we shall see no evil
we shall hear no evil because our angels
are there to guide the way he got on top
and slowly inserted himself
what is that
he was reading excerpts from books he
wanted banned
and he's like this ultra-conservative
like 80 year old let me pull it up
because it's funny as I'm going to
give you the of your life
you have to see him yeah
yeah
it was good I can't wait to have your
in my mouth
here
oh boy oh my God
and I will quote from it please do
I put some lube on and got him on his
knees
and I began to slide into it
I pulled out of him and kissed him
man went through the entire Public
Library like a condom on himself pulled
out his favorite lines this was my ass
okay I was struggling to imagine someone
inside me that's right Mr Kennedy he got
to slide that over here slowly inserted
himself into me yeah it was the worst
pain I think I have ever felt in my life
go on I love it
mix of pleasure it was soon pleasure and
close quote that's it all boys aren't
blue
that's the work of art in its own thank
you Senator thank you senator
oh well so we don't have we don't have a
sponsor today so what I will say
this is huge very important breaking
news right now yes is um
we're having a flash
flood flash
flood tsunami sale Run for the hills
it's just a little Last Chance sale for
some styles that are getting a little
old on the website and there's some
random sizes left and stuff this one's
basically sold out looks like oh well
there's some actually there's small in
this beige
you guys better head over there quick
but there's a ton of styles uh
teddyfresh.com beautiful stuff that I
love this is all stuff that's on sale
there's still good stuff I mean I see
lots of sold outs but if you go there
there's still a lot of good stuff
there's a chance you'll find something
good I feel like
going down going down
this is all happening right now wow just
kind of clearing some space in the
warehouse teddyfresh.com
tet weird sizes sale
but it is true it's not all weird sizes
oh
no it's all good it's all good sizes
you're not weird right
besides there's no such thing as normal
sizes
well it is normal what is a normal size
look at all this is all on sale I'm
still going they'll get all this
good ass on sale I'm literally
and pissing right now like
god the owners have lost their
goddamn mind look at this women's double
pleat trousers was a hundred it's now
40. what
are you is that right yeah that's not a
typo no break out the Straight Jackets
because the owners have lost their
marbles do you need to see somebody oh
perfectly
perfectly fine look at this hat for
example was 35 it's now 17.50
perfectly huh it's all still on sale I'm
still going my favorite things
27 from 45.
this it's sold out you were too slow
oh man this is gonna make me sad but I'm
gonna click it anyway the cute but
deadly is on sale
at half price it looks like and I know
Shredder modeled this oh the shredder
picks gone
I think we switched to a bigger dog
in a variety of sizes this yo
what the hell it's like a dog out of
here it's like a police dog when in
diversity like what what
well it was cute or with shredder no
offense to this dog he looks very nice I
think it's um Rosa's dog from the office
he looks very nice be polite yeah I was
gonna say I've seen the dog downstairs
yeah
I know that joke I don't trust that dog
um
we're still scrolling we're scrolling
and there it is that's the bottom wow
unreal yeah yeah Now's the Time people
a lot of Applause for the flash sale
Round of Applause
pettyfresh.com by the way next week I
think we should do these the sub-a-thon
or the sub Drive I had an idea oh you
had an idea because I had an idea too
I meant to talk to you about it
Sam
is incoming with everything you need so
the idea was that
it'd be fun to do a some kind of drive
to bolster memberships okay and so I
thought I don't know what it'll be maybe
like every 100 I don't know where I
drink people like when I get drunk
okay I don't know but maybe you have a
better idea dude that's not going to be
very long episode I thought that's true
100 that's not gonna be very long yeah
we would have to work it out I mean we
can maybe incorporate this oh I I'm
gonna need that
what do you think about
karaoke with the clients oh God I hate
karaoke I don't know what that means
well I hate karaoke well and you know
why Zach loves it because people who can
sing Love karaoke
and you guys are so annoying that's true
you ever been to karaoke with that one
person he just tries
look I'm not even that good of a singer
yeah right I'm just saying I think it's
fun
you want to do you want to do the
karaoke no I mean if we're gonna do
something maybe we could do like Guitar
Hero you know that then I would shine
right you know in a gameplay so what
does that mean damn well it could mean
we could structure it somehow like
um people could bid for What song they
want you to perform so we could have
like a we could come up with like a big
list of songs and then you know the fans
with uh by hitting certain Milestones
could force you to sing some song that
you really don't want to do or would be
embarrassed to do or whatever you know
what I mean I like that idea yeah cool
with that right away we can also uh we'd
have to do it in a way obviously where
um we'd under like obviously the episode
we got claimed for like playing karaoke
music or whatever but hopefully not
locked exactly so we could pre-test and
make sure there's no blocked music
playing music is fine and we just go for
it and you know the incentive would be
to drive Subs well I can tell you what
the people are gonna want me to sing is
it gonna be a Friday uh
could be whatever okay they're gonna
want me to sing the Klein water man well
then you're just gonna have to do it I
guess so the tune in to find out see
what happens
the Klein water huh yeah
uh can we still drink
that's what we should still we should
work in both drinking drinking is part
of karaoke yeah it goes hand in hand oh
yeah it's the biggest trick in the year
that's right karaoke night is the
biggest I think if we combine those two
and maybe even a third one if we have
good suggestions then we could have a
heck of an episode on our hands let's
smoke some crack
oh yeah ten thousand I'll hit the pipe
right yo I will smoke crack Live on
YouTube
pregnant
[Music]
cool is that okay to say I mean he is a
crack baby Beetlejuice well crack it
with me uh uh Beetlejuice from Howard I
don't think he is I don't know his mom
smoked crack that's how he ended up like
that
I thought he was okay I could be wrong
uh he always gone no his his the lores
his mom smoked crack when she was
pregnant with them I'm pretty sure got
it that's some more yeah
but I don't know if you have a different
thing about nobody or maybe I'm thinking
of crack there's a crackhead Bob
character maybe he's crackhead bod
smoked too much crack that's why he oh
okay okay yeah well anyway the joke was
in poor taste let's just forget about it
clearly not meant to be too uh
to analyze here yeah let's let's move it
right along let's keep it moving folks
so as we promised we have a really fun
show
I still stand by that
um we have a rectangular dance dropped
our boy I am rectangular
I follow that are you feeling
rectangular today or what
what shape you feeling
what polygon I was feeling rectangular
all week but today I'm kind of feeling
like circlish oh really oh I'm so sorry
yeah cringe you're just like all the
rest
well let's see NPC Circle He travel
we're trying to get him in the studio so
he can be like I traveled 3 000
kilometers just to do this because he
seems pretty down to travel for like the
littlest reason
actually just to do this just is just
for this
so here he is he invented a dance
and I promise there is audio okay
we'll get to that in just a moment yeah
travel a thousand kilometers to New York
City for a video that now has a million
views wow thank you guys for sharing as
a result I made up a dance for you here
it goes let's go this is a dance frog
[Music]
it's not what I expected when he said he
made a dance what do you mean
well when people say dance you expect
they're at least one of their feet to
lift from the ground
but it is kind of catchy I'm not even
gonna lie like it's not yeah yeah I
think we all need to learn it can we all
practice right now uh I don't think I
really can the dance oh yeah he's in
compassion he has a doctor's note he
doesn't have to do it right Kim brought
me he brought me a doctor's note
he's like here's my doctor's note I said
what for what you didn't miss work
there's a suit I'm still in that school
mindset we gotta bring in I didn't even
know anything buddy I was like what do
you want me to do with this I don't
think anyone thought twice about it
until you brought them like it's a
little weird where were you but also I'm
not gonna I'm really broken I'm not
gonna like
say I need a doctor's note
how do you need a day just to cover my
bases God damn what's next I don't feed
you sounds kind of sketch are you doing
something else Kim this is cover up
what it's an alibi look at that face you
almost I'd look the red-handed
who did you kill cam nobody was Ashton
Kutcher there no
I'm a demigod in fact uh investor he's
below me all right here everyone ready
who has eight two able hands sorry to be
ableist today too Kim right okay you
one-handed freak all right we start
hands wide all right here it is in views
wow thank you guys for sharing
up a dance for you
yes sucks
no offense bro but a thousand miles
terrible dance
no dabs you didn't even dab once bro
I am rectangular
[Music]
very cool that's much better at least I
tried I didn't and I didn't travel a
thousand miles to do that either only
like 10.
he's awesome though I love him okay he's
a great guy uh shout out to rectangular
he's a great guy we don't know anything
about him great guy I don't know I get
good vibes he's green
you know Green is a good color it's a
nice color yeah
Jimmy we talked about Jimmy on Howard
this is quite a good little mini game I
saw in the subreddit
and actually I'll tell you I found it
quite hard I did a few I didn't want to
spoil it because I want to do it on the
show but thank you first of all to Misha
the lab ass lavaski
whose hair
work with me a Jimmy Lee
or the dictator
it might seem harder than you think
let's go ahead is everybody ready to
play all right work with me here we go
number one is it Jimmy Lee or the
dictator I think that's right that's so
good I think that's Kim Young yeah I
have a dictator oh it can be multiple
it's not just mouth there's 14 slides oh
wow all different dictators that's right
pages so you think that's Kim I am sure
that Kim okay and you haven't seen this
right no okay let's see it is it Kim
Jong-un
it is
hairline wow
who's ready for round number two great
Kim jong-un's like I am rectangular here
it is the only one feeling holes is his
uncle he tied to a tree and shot a
rocket
that did happen actually that was a film
all right up next whose hairline is this
is this Jimmy Lee or dictator I think
[Music]
is this
installing
it is
[Applause]
that man knows his dictator hairlines I
will tell you impressive impressive all
right congratulations up next let's see
if you can get this one though it only
gets harder from here interesting
oh boy that's our boy for sure is that
Jimmy or a dictator wait wait wait
hold it no yeah
that might be Kim jong's Son hold on
yeah now there is confusion is it Jimmy
or not yeah I think that that is
final answer I immediately thought that
was Jimmy but now
anyone else want to it sounds pretty
convincing I think Jimmy AB says it's
Jimmy Lee okay and then Dan is saying it
is Kim
Jong-il ill he's sick
Kim Jong-il is which one is it
[Music]
[Applause]
I really saw that hairline there yeah I
was just looking for the first one that
looked filled in right it really did
look like his hair though let's take a
look I mean it's really right on me
seemed like it could have been his
hairline yeah right his hair looks
thicker I feel like Jimmy's you could
see was like a little bit translucent
yeah for the top well here this is when
he was a little bit older oh that is
very true but regardless it was Jimmy I
was wrong they don't with side runs
that much well there it is it's harder
than you thought people sure is moving
on to our next contestant is the Jimmy
Lee or the dictator
Jimmy Lee or the dictator that's Jimmy
Kim says that's Jimmy
I'm questioning everything now because I
got thrown on that last one is it Jimmy
Lee or or a dictator I'm gonna go
dictator I just don't know which one
we've got dictators we've got Jimmy
Lee's there's clearly a split
interesting interesting
time is running out time for an answer
it's pretty full I'm I'm not I'm not
sure and lock it in and lost his Groove
I lost the groove lock it in myself I'm
gonna say it's Jimmy all right here it
is uh
it is
so close so close so close
I'm so upset right now
it's not cool well sometimes you get
them sometimes you sometimes you eat the
bar and sometimes Kim Jong-un eats your
food and you starve that's right
not a lot of food in North Korea that's
the joke
thank you thank you
all right up next oh
look at this
wow is this Jimmy Lee or a dictator
you decide
take it in
dictator again I just don't know which
one this hairstyle is called the
headphones
something about mass murder that just
makes the hairline wrist seed
it's either it's either genocide or
lidocaine am I right
I'm gonna
I think it's Mao I mean it seems too
obvious but I think it is Mel dances Mao
Avie says Jimmy Lee there's only one
answer I think Mao Mao yeah it's
young I felt like they were gonna maybe
try and trip us up here I don't know
that's a good one well done sir
well done
what Target do you think though folks
now take a now take this in
this is an iconic hairline my friends
but is it dictatorial dictatorial I say
Jamie or is it one up dentist
that's one up I think that's one
up dentist as well yep I'm gonna
go with dictator just because I think
there might be something there it is up
something up there that is Jimmy Lee
absolutely and that's a beautiful
hairline wow
[Music]
who could forget uh such a hairline like
that
thank you moving on the final category
let's take a look here oh that's it
don't push
harder than you think though isn't it
yeah well shout out to Misha the labsky
here for uh thank you for playing
everybody it's some Jimmy Lear dictator
in today's episode brought to you by
Misha the lapsky appreciate that so much
tune in next time when we play is it
lupus or just a rash
play that
pretty much every episode
all right see you next time and remember
you're still those with lupus
it's not your fault
all right see you next time
adopt a pet
space
everybody new to your pets
um
fun times eh
okay this this is so funny and odd
now
this without the recent context we've
had of her doing like an apology tour
for
Shane and and uh Colleen
what seems so out of pocket Adam DeVine
on a podcast said Jojo siwa
is a straight up he didn't I'm
paraphrasing b word he's like I don't
like her at all and she's again she's
like 20 or and I don't know when this
took place but
well he basically did in so many words
and like it would have seemed so out of
pocket but now it's just funny I mean
what do you guys think about this let's
take a listen this is Adam DeVine of
Workaholics Fame and so much more I mean
he is bigger than that righteous
gemstones Pitch Perfect he's funny he's
he's funny he's a talent he is a talent
wonderful singer I'm gonna give JoJo see
why the benefit of the doubt because uh
and I was prepared to really like her so
it bums me out but maybe she was just
having a uh an off day or maybe she just
absolutely doesn't give a which
could very well be the case
um she's from Omaha so I'm like oh is
she yeah and so I go yeah I'm from Omaha
and she was like
totally dude she's a legend mate no dude
super fake and when she she's like kind
of rude backstage
some people gotta tell the truth and
when she came in front of the camera she
would like light up and suddenly she's a
different person and she wasn't that
person before the cameras but to be
perfectly honest uh I did not like her
that much she was not that cool we
wanted to really like her because I you
know I'm like this is cool she's from
Omaha I'll give JoJo maybe she's having
a bad day what though maybe she's
talking about that
absolutely insane whoever did this needs
to go go back to the beginning
this was a nightmare everybody not
interested in making any friends so you
would hate her however it's so it's
funny how out-of-pocket it is
yeah but now it's got me thinking like
hmm
what if she does suck
what if she is a giant b word I mean
like you said maybe she was just having
an off day that day it was funny either
way yeah just throw out of pocket I like
him would also think that she would just
be like a really nice wholesome person
all right yeah and they had Omaha you
they had the Omaha connection you know
but I respect Adam he seems like a nice
guy and
definitely not somebody that would look
in on his murder girlfriend then yeah he
wouldn't go home wait what are we oh
what like if Adam walked in on his
girlfriend brutally murdered yeah he's
the type of guy that would call the
police right right immediately not his
co-star right can I say something not
write a letter for it I don't even
understand
the explanation for doing that finding
the body
is not a crime
you're fine I mean well it's all first
of all a conspiracy anyway but but I
think the conspiracy is that he didn't
want to be involved at all that's just
awesome if you ever watched a movie it's
kind of scary to be the person calling
the police yeah you're like the one
suspected
and he's the boyfriend
I don't know it's it's way more shady to
not call them if you don't want to be a
suspect yeah well also we know in
retrospect that she was dead but he
didn't know that
well he goes I looked in and I saw wine
everywhere yeah that's you know but like
weird if you see your girlfriend
bleeding on the floor you look in and
you see her bleeding on the floor you're
like out peace and just like oh she's
probably dead I gotta go right like
that's right insane no matter
how well you slice it yeah no he's not
or not be like I gotta do something yeah
like maybe she's still alive bleeding
out on the floor maybe I should help
right he was probably thinking acts kind
of over her anyway that's why it's so
crazy it wasn't working on to the next
one I'm Ashton Kutcher
[Music]
I'm an angel I'm an angel man after an
angel God damn it
this was Ashton when he saw his uh dead
girlfriend
right yes
the benefit of the doubt because I love
you Adam
we love you girl oh
there's a donation from Drew 30-month
member who said they met JoJo one that
uh at a Denny's no super rude and she
was farting no no no no stops you all by
herself that's all planned out that
didn't happen was her name Ethan Klein
no her name's JoJo siwa why would her
name be anything what if they just got
them confused like from a distance we
literally don't care let's look the same
yeah
we couldn't wait a minute I don't even
know why you guys are saying that so 20
toes both of you
listen you guys remember
excuse me Prince I.E
or Prince E A sorry he's the guy I made
a video about him all the time
if any of you guys are you guys are that
oh I do he made a video about look up
yeah super like hipster this is like
anti phones let me call into the podcast
like on like one of the really early
podcasts and we talked Prince EA yeah
yeah you would always say it like that
wait he did like so I do apologize
because he was right I remember we did
went that down that rabbit hole I swear
wait I think you're right but this is
such a big memory that I I'm talking
like first 50 well hold on let's do it
podcast a dream was a dream or something
that really happened yeah he did no did
he princess
princeier responds to H3 he yeah oh so
maybe we did but we had goofed onions
because I was talking about how what did
he say about it really like I remember
he was Escape complimentary yeah oh he
was nice well he was like killing us
with kindness he killed us with kindness
from what I remember he would do that
yeah
you know a lot of people say that Jay
Shetty is the new Prince EA yes
[Music]
it's a little more Savvy I would think
so help yeah he's a little even more
savvy than princeier uh but princeier's
still popping right is he on he's
probably big on Facebook it seems like
he's down on the ground
but I'm curious what he said uh are we
on the same page I don't know maybe you
know let's talk about it let's talk
about it let's have a conversation come
down and have a chat you know
let me know
um from easy to connect with but yeah he
was nice I remember which pissed me off
I hate when people are nice
he has 18 million on Facebook does his
videos get views
uh it used to be back then I don't know
it's hey it's so hard to see the views
on Facebook Facebook is such a
it's so bad I don't understand how
people use it only straight up it's
literally designed like only parents
older people then why am I always like
confused on how to do anything because
it's like aren't the Boomers confused
you're trying too hard
like I think Facebook and I haven't been
on Facebook in like five years but I
think the way it's meant is just it just
tells you what to think and feel and do
you just scroll I guess as a user and I
honestly think because just recently we
had to do something with the uh with uh
the H3 Facebook page for something we
had to like take somebody off and add
them on a new account or whatever and it
took me like 10 minutes to just find
yeah how to do that like sounds
about right
yeah I hate it his most recent little
videos 2.7 K views 3.4k that's also the
Facebook curse it's like you're in
you're out
but anyway the point I why I saw a
prince EA video
that was great on tick tock
you guys know there's like a new genre
of videos on Tick Tock of people in
grocery stores yelling at you about how
mundane grocery items are killing you
y'all seen that no I don't it's one of
my favorite genres I mean I guess yeah I
guess I know what you mean they go those
types of videos the one that they're on
about now is like canola oil is the most
inflammatory thing in the world you will
die if you put this in your body instead
use 100 Cal lard what they're serious
they're on some weird kick about how
seed oils is now the biggest Health
crisis and they're they it's just total
nonsense these guys are total charlatans
so EA joined uh
joined in but he actually has what I can
only it's the most out of pocket most
insane one I've seen yet not really he
always does it nuts so bigger
girl dude and I'm like this is a take
that I couldn't even I never imagined
that anyone could possibly take but just
listen to what he says here let's hear
it of course this is brought To Us by
uh I follow all these like doctors who
debunk so I think I see a lot of it
there but Dr Ed's love you buddy
Izzy
love is
it is what it is
okay wait well okay just listen to
this guy God damn it God damn it we got
it man okay
wait but dude now you're talking over
the best part oh my God okay ready here
we go
eating fresh food supermarket fresh
this man said stop eating fresh food
seriously
okay
bro
just kidding me a cup of frozen spinach
has four times the amount dude he's
literally just making up it's nuts
this is like a comedy stop eating fresh
food it's like a parody of one of those
videos
it is stop eating vegetables dude there
are people that say oh yeah I'm not even
kidding the carnivore guys they go in
the grocery store and they yell stop
eating vegetables vegetables have
defense mechanisms they call it like
phytoplanktons or something that so bad
it it
poisons your body I swear to God and
they go just dumb they just go just eat
meat and cheese and milk because it's
better for you than broccoli
stop eating fresh food
so just fiber iron and calcium compared
to Fresh they're huge Freighters too
what's funny about this guy his last
video is literally stop eating canned
foods then he tells you stop eating
fresh food You're supposed to eat well
I'm done I'm fasting right now because
clearly I'm not allowed to eat anything
that's cool you know we live in a
society where 73 of the U.S food supply
is comprised of ultra processed food so
when people are actively trying to
change this we now have people like him
telling him to stop eating Fresh Foods
also why do these people make up random
statistics in every video he does know
we can just look them up right well they
said he looked at exactly that what
happens to Mineral fiber and phenolic
retention in eight fresh or frozen
fruits and veggies they even included
spinach surprise surprise the majority
of the commodity showed no significant
difference between fresh and frozen for
all measures oh and look here again
most people would say right yeah but
yeah I would agree with that
overall the vitamin content of the
Frozen Commodities was comparable to and
occasionally higher than that of their
fresh counterparts okay so he's like
almost right no well because he said
four times as much nutrients he's not
almost right he said stop eating fresh
food
that part is definitely not right
like that's psycho I'm sorry you can't
just go out in the world and say that
some some fresh food
thank you doctor it's I love doctor
thank you drizz and a few others I
followed really do it justice because
like this video did pretty good for IDs
I see it as 24 000 likes but the
original videos they're really go viral
people are like on them oh yeah no seed
oil
no vegetables or fruits bro is there is
this is the seed oil thing like I hear
people talking about that I haven't
looked it's a Joe Rogan thing I think
too like it's full mainstream now my
seed no vegetables no no the uh the
seeds like the biggest Health crisis
facing Humanity today like they're so uh
alarmist about it and it turns out as Dr
is has shown time and time again uh
canola oil and other seed oils actually
lower inflammation when compared to
animal products my seed is all over this
place I'm so nasty
um
yeah so stop eating Fresh Foods okay
done
unless that that leaf has 30 seconds
from ground to Plate otherwise it's it's
dead
here I have put you guys to find some
more let's see
[Music]
hold on we're having a technical issue
oh we got a technical issue can you all
fix that or is that like a technical
issue it's a technical issue okay hold
on just a little technical issue here
yeah we heard food coming out they
probably have a common ancestor I'll say
that yeah I got you one that wasn't too
bright I got you the saladito family
doesn't has the best stock in town
the saladino surname and I apologies to
all the saladinos in chat
so here's another we probably missed the
beginning of that we were talking about
this guy Paul saladino listen if you eat
salads as a saddle saladino you're okay
in my book with her boob coming out so
listen to this psycho about the seed
oils man it's crazy this is how I eat
out avoiding seed oils I'm in New York
City I'm gonna try this app called seed
oil Scout and look for restaurants by
the way I'm gonna try this app how much
you want to bet that he owns it he's
invested yeah yeah Angels here's a
restaurant
it actually has a blue check mark on the
app which means it's like an OG place it
doesn't use seed oils sounds amazing
let's go check it out and we'll see what
we find I'm curious what kind of oils do
you cook in here because we use butter
extra virgin olive oil and beef towel
fat this is a Portlandia sketch totally
well it's like the opposite though it's
like a Joe Rogan roganian sketch it's
interesting yeah interesting how things
have uh evolved over the last decade
they became the right I mean they don't
see what they're doing these are the Bro
Science they're the ones sitting at the
table
does this have canola in it
that's not gonna work have you not read
the literature
burger that has liver and heart in it
can you cook that in Tallow for me on
the grill yes amazing and then you guys
have a rib eye too right yes grass-fed
rib eye with a bone marrow as well
what's what's the cow's name
right and was he was he a massage what
kind of music did he enjoy is she a
Taurus
get any um ice baths at all cow Style
the milk Donny cow style cow style
okay amazing that's it thank you sir it
looks like grass-fed this man eats this
every meal he will die soon
he will he will disprove his own
theories very soon I mean
he probably does relatively okay right
there's no way he eats exclusively red
meat and oh oh okay sorry he he's I
thought it was just the no seed oil
because like no this is the carnivore
and adorable right this guy he's his I
got you yeah okay he's for sure gonna
die soon
like there's no shot this guy is going
to live much longer his heart is just an
overdrive man
and I know I'm not the model hell so you
guys go crazy with that on Tick Tock but
I have eaten vegetables lately were they
fresh
oh well
don't hit play me like that
it's Tallow only salt we got here it's a
variety Burger
theatello french fries awesome thank you
these would be the fries to eat because
they are potatoes cooked and Tallow
that's disgusting the burgers it's gonna
be a feast cooked in beef fat like how
vile can you get
sounds healthy
it for sure is not like I know it's not
stop trying to convince me I don't know
so this is the whole genre I don't know
who's watching this but it's pretty
interesting but this is what all your
boyfriends who watch Joe Rogan are doing
I guarantee if all you ladies out there
whose boyfriends watch Joe Rogan ask
them about seed oils
that'll be a fun experiment
here they're gonna be so into you
they're like oh I'm so glad you asked
girl
this psycho goes in a grocery store
shirtless and yells at you
stop eating seed oils how about just put
on a shirt and shoes for God's sakes man
chips all of these chips seed oils every
single thing oh my God seed oils or why
do you look why are you like this
I would be scared if I walked as I was
walking through the grocery store I saw
a shirtless shoeless guy yelling raving
about seed oils I would walk all the way
around here yeah
soybean sunflower oh holy dude
every single thing you're telling me
that Lays potato chips aren't good for
you no don't say it this is revelatory
don't say it mind-blowing information do
you see how psycho his eyes are
this is a man in full psychosis
he's in full psychosis
he is not healthy a mind body or Spirit
sound good yo can we get some lays up in
this by the way you mean like
oh Dan's going for the seed oils you're
shaving off you're shaving off Years
buddy don't do it
can you find the doctor is debunking
this just so I can show people the yeah
the counter avoid this debunking the
seed oil thing yeah
Cheeto is actually good for you based on
what uh the literature I see well he was
saying something about like inflammation
is that true is it no seed oil actually
reduces inflammation based on clinical
trials
about the anti-inflammatory right now
that's probably not true because they're
deep fried let's see it's deep fried
hell yeah it is vegetable oils canola
sunflower
that's the worst one safflower let's go
you know what's the worst one rapeseed
oil
that does sound bad it's actually just
canola oil
I still as a full-grown adult cannot get
over the fact that it's called a rape
scene I thought you were making like a
stupid joke it's called rape seed that's
his actual name
canola oil is 100 rape seed that's crazy
it must be some weird translation
because in your in a lot of European
languages it's like wraps
watch I'll have Google say it no I know
it's like that in English but it's in
Swedish is drops
vocalized so let's see say it Google I
dare you
Maybe I'm Wrong though here's the top
comment British problems rapeseed oil
really needs a Rebrand
yeah I mean what the hell
how God
freaking dang it dude how wait what
yo this apple is really blowing it this
Apple product here yeah what's going on
I need a Dell
[Applause]
I need a Dell right now dude you're
getting a Dell dude
something like a residency in Vegas I
heard something like that Adele Adele
okay here it is guys
here it is
say it rapeseed
that's crazy grape seed
as what it is you know like you mean r
word our word Siege exactly thank you
grape seed
grape seed oil
you could just say canola oil though I'm
pretty sure it's the same thing
um
there it is
I sent that Tick Tock thank you
four reasons why I watch this dumbass I
haven't actually seen this guy this is a
new one is this an anti-vegetable guy
uh yeah I don't eat vegetables number
one one I don't like them they taste
icky
I agree two the texture's weird and it
gives me gas but lepson's obsolets and
phytates which can prevent the
absorption of the vitamins and minerals
that I found number two most crops are
sprayed with pesticides herbicides and
many of the toxic chemicals even the
organic ones number three they
commitment I mean that probably is a
real concern
I think that concern is pretty overblown
as well frankly the whole pesticides
thing
but okay I mean if that's just talking
about how there's no more bugs like a
week ago I think it's usually more like
that doesn't have a mental issue it's
not right the mass industrial use of
pesticides I didn't say that I'm talking
about eating it into your body right
right talking about the health concerns
of eating it
all the bugs are dead probably fine
it's a different thing
inside of me he's not saying I care
about the bugs he's saying I I don't
want to eat his pesticides inside of me
get inside of me
I feel pretty uncomfortable and number
four most of them taste
oh he actually said
he said bro you're a grown-ass man who
just said vegetables are icky I think he
has a point I mean I don't know what you
guys are buzzing about you guys missed
number three but he said number three is
fart all day too so I don't know he did
yeah wait that's another joke I made
yeah he did all the dumb things
they're super poisonous and also they're
icky and make me fart
just eat meat so you can have fat logs
like me
so here's Dr is on the rape seed thing
let's take a listen it turns out seed
oils are inflammatory and animal fats
are anti-inflammatory and we have
control trials in humans proving us from
school this control study took 13
overweight men in which all participants
had both interventions and after an
overnight fast they consumed a muffin
either containing 50 grams of butter or
50 grams of sunflower oil they found
that after the consumption of the butter
muffin the inflammatory biomarker
interleukin-6 increased whereas after
the sunflower oil muffins several
inflammatory markers decreased oh wait
but that means seedels are
anti-inflammatory and butter is
inflammatory no no no no that's got to
be a mistake it's got to be funded by
big sunflower oh right it's not okay if
you said that for you yesterday
big sunflower oil
people and fed them a diet high in
vegetable oils or saturated fat from
they found that the vegetable oil group
lost liver fat and improved metabolic
status without weight loss whereas the
butter group had higher liver fat
insulin cholesterol LDL and
triglycerides concluding vegetable oils
does not cause any signs of inflammation
wait what's going on okay but this one
has to be a review of 37 randomized
control trials looking at dietary fats
and inflammatory markers found that out
of the 10 control trials on vegetable
oils none of them found convincing
evidence of increasing circulatory
inflammatory markers and actually three
of the studies on vegetable oils found
in anti-inflammatory effects oh look at
that I guess I wasn't wrong after all
sea doors are not inflammatory and in
many cases health healthier than animal
fats and if you don't agree the only
conclusion left is that you clearly
can't read facts don't care about your
feelings oh he did it he did it he did
it
[Music]
um yeah sometimes your your common sense
is enough eating butter is not good for
you
they go what's just healthier sunflower
oil or butter let's not go crazy
I mean
what's worse for you a bucket of bacon
grease or sunflower oil
I need a tick tock to tell me
I think I better be done because I feel
like I'm just ruining it now
oh
something's happening
actually nothing is happening
anyway what do you think is healthier a
bucket of bacon fat or seed oil some
sunflower seeds
nuts are healthy boy
get out of here something about weight
loss in there right with the seed oils
so I'm kind of working out right now
yeah right deep fried potato chips baby
so there that is uh Prince I.E took me
eea took me down
the rabbit hole there pretty fun times
with print the prince but that was that
was the craziest take I'd heard yet stop
eating fresh food that's awesome
it's so fun
stop eating fresh food stop it
is happening um
moving on
oh I don't know who watched the one
piece
a show on Netflix but Luffy the actor
spotted
in a Teddy fresh hat
let's go family and he's in Brazil how
did this happen or he is Brazilian or is
I don't know if he where he lives now
this is from 2020 he's 20 now I think
and so this would make him eight that's
from a while ago yeah from two years ago
yeah that's an old hat that's what I
told the marketing team to reach out I
don't know if they have yet family
yeah that's an older style definitely
so
I thought you were great dude in one
piece you know loving what I'm seeing
people if he was a fan he would have
been so when before you watch it when
you were on it
no but I love it now I know but what if
he is no longer he bailed come back
I loved it we love you
we love you come back come to Brazil
come from Brazil
there that is hey uh Jimmy Lee's uh
number one fan base Brazil oh maybe
that's something probably a fan of Jimmy
yeah that's how he knows about it I'll
have Jimmy reach out maybe he can hook
us up all right
now I don't know how much water this
holds but Jeffree Star came out recently
and said James Charles is a cycle he
also came out and did a whole big diss
on Trisha
oh he's Mexican I read that he's
Brazilian you grew up in Mexico City
oh I think it's because you the
character is supposed to be Brazilian
right well because I remember he lives
in Mexico
uh let's see because I I just I I know I
heard that he's Brazilian
you know because then Jimmy can't help
us if he's Mexican the writer of the uh
the original
confirmed that if they lived in the real
world Luffy would be from Brazil maybe
that's just what you were remembering
Jimmy Cannon I've heard that but I think
it was something else Jimmy can in fact
help us because uh in the top five of
his audience point five percent is from
Mexico
Jimmy has that yeah top five percent is
Mexican point five percent point five
yes that's pretty good yeah
all right anyway here's yeah also uh
Jeffree Star also made a huge diss
against Trisha that was kind of
interesting I saw people
actually to be fair I think he kind of
has a point too
I mean but here let's watch this one
about uh
what was Jeffrey canceled for I'm not
super up to date with the Jeffrey Lore
um uh
a slew of things
um racism
uh being very cruel very horrible videos
from like his past coming to light
law among amongst other things okay
okay well so here is on James Charles at
least he's got that he's one of the only
people at least out here saying it
I don't know if that counts for anything
I thought that I could expose someone
else's trauma and story to x out someone
else that person did not want me to
therefore this person is still free and
to see this person still out there
they're not thriving like they used to
be at all it's just interesting but the
industry does have demon demonic snakes
he's the biggest piece of in the
beauty industry wow and he allegedly has
done a lot of horrible things he
admitted to talking to minors he is a
people so that is true I just
see I always stay out of the drama he
did a video
allegedly not allegedly admitting to
minors one of the most vile human beings
on this planet and I have never really
talked or addressed these things but he
is a literal monster people
aren't ready for the truth everyone
wants to keep their mouth shut and they
keep why right if someone is bad let
people know yeah no I have A-list
celebrities literally using this
yes Kim Kardashian we're talking to you
he's not using his makeup absolutely you
have to tell me who it is later so I can
steer clear of that human oh his name is
James Charles I'm sorry but the ending
of that was iconic that's awesome but uh
this is not iconic uh this is the
headline
Jeffrey Star accusers say the makeup
Mogul has a history of essay physical
violence and hush money offers
yeah
that's what that's what the headline
says oh but it's written by a cat 10
barge
and cheese
I gotta read the article I haven't read
the article right anything good in there
in that
I am always suspicious of Jeffree Star I
don't know why I don't even know much
about him but
The Vibes are definitely off The Vibes
are kind of scary The Vibes are
definitely scary enough yeah and also
I mean he's been working with Shane for
a while even when weird was known
about him
right but it's not that well
no James is actively like yeah
predatoring
miners
you know what I mean oh yeah but there
is there is definitely a bit of irony
there for sure yeah
for sure
uh I am curious what's the Jeffree Star
stuff though because I really don't know
yeah because I feel like send me the
article let me read it yeah here I got
it we weren't really talking about him
at that time I guess when I think he was
already like um basically like canceled
by the time we so we never got into it
got into that world before building his
YouTube makeup Empire Jeffree Star was
Politically Incorrect Myspace celebrity
that's I didn't know that
five people told Insider that in 2009
star used a taser on a homeless teen the
who had rejected his affection in a
movie theater
let me read that again
2009 Jeffree Star
used a taser on a homeless teen who had
a oh so so Jeffrey was hitting on the
homeless kid and then tasered him
because he he didn't want to he didn't
like the attention
am I reading that correct
that's that this man does not take a
rejection well
hey baby you want to uh come back to my
place no I'm good well you
the team later stayed the night in
star's apartment and told Insider that
star gave him Ambien
until he was intoxicated and forcib
forcibly performed
on him without his consent that's like
really serious several people in public
and publicly available internet post
corroborate key components of the former
homeless teen's account what the
that's crazy
well apparently you can do anything you
want to homeless people
it is sad that's why serial killers
usually go for like that's why I I was
saying I got scary vibes from him
that is really scary that is really
scary
Arthur and star went to see a movie with
two friends during the film Arthur said
star tried to hold his hand but Arthur
resisted according to Arthur star
attacked him with a taser in the theater
parking lot
after the movie and retaliation
what
well
Mackenzie says I saw Jeffree Star
standing by himself two years in a row
at Warped Tour and The Vibes were so
scary I couldn't get close
that's the real crime
he has bad Chi you might say all right
or nen is that what they called it
Hunter Hunter
then he is Batman his Nan is foul bro
it's not bad
wow
Arthur later recanted his statement and
reached out to another Insider source to
offer 10 000 allegedly on behalf of star
to walk back their comments
to the outlet as well now in a new
report published Monday Insider says it
has obtained documentation demonstrating
that Arthur allegedly received 45
000 in hush money
CFO of Jeffrey uh buy from Scott Andrew
CFO of Jeffree Star cosmetics
what the fridge that's pretty that is
pretty scandalous
that's definitely top tier psycho
yeah also he kills Yaks man he does he
said we actually sent us some yeah oh
yeah I never liked that the yak thing
was the yak uh Saga yakity yeah don't
talk back or I'll make jerky out of you
[Applause]
God you're such a dad
thank you both dad jokes pretty good
though it made me laugh
dude that's actually nuts that's nuts
man
that's nuts bro
nuts see that's the stuff I hadn't heard
I had not heard that based on what
Jeffree Star is calling other people to
do it sounds like people should start
talking about Jeffree Star yo there's
even look at this
an old tweet he erased going to the
movies with and he added the dude Gage
Arthur
that he apparently tasered and drugged
I taught people carry a taser for
self-defense
he's doing it for self-offense
wow oh so here's the Trisha Paytas thing
and I don't care
it's just it's short it's short
you can just keep painting pretend you
don't hear it okay thank you you want to
hear mom you're not even Associated okay
I can't hear you what
all right Eli's not here you guys she's
roll and roll out of the frame yeah you
want to roll out a frame for this so
when it gets clipped you don't have to
be in it just crawler
hide
[Laughter]
remember if we had so the reason why I
think it's he has a point is just
because I was there when she was saying
this stuff about him because she told
this whole elaborate story about how
he was like super mean to her and was
bullying her and stuff and now she's
like oh I don't even remember I don't
even know what we're fighting about
and he's like what which you know Fair
Point to him
uh does this have what Trisha originally
said about him I don't see it I kind of
wanted to show that just quickly it's
short
I don't think it's short
well just to give an idea because she
was like he's the worst person alive
which might be true based on other
things
but she's like we went to Vegas he
bullied me they made fun of him they
called me fat like just really demon
and of course I uh wasn't that the the
hairdresser or something I think it was
more complicated than that uh no it
wasn't I went back and watched the clip
it really wasn't complicated
there's a highlight of it you just you
know just link me that okay
okay
um and now here she is like uh
what is this a fan of what he recently
saw of her which seemed to be a clip of
her downplaying their friendship ending
saying that she didn't remember what
happened now I have looked pretty hard
to try and find the exact video that
Jeffrey is watching it kind of sounds
like he's reacting to a compilation
right here
because Trisha doesn't seem like she's
in a place where she even wants to be a
drama like that as she was recently God
damn it to him
God when she was talking about him on
Tana's podcast Jeffree Star councilman
oh my gosh
um
a different era I'm going to say not
candle honestly seriously because I hate
having beef in general or like looming
things over my head like I would just
say not cancel to be cool with everyone
but Jeffrey was not a fan of what he
recently saw of her which seemed to be a
okay
what is this what did you this was uh
let's get him everyone I'm scared of
everyone oh yes yeah this was it this
was it
no Jeffrey's cool yeah I think we like
had like I don't know maybe we didn't
have beef I don't know sometimes you
know you think about like why did we
fall out sometimes I forget I was just a
hot mess I just like dated everyone for
a minute that was the point so she says
I don't even remember why we fell out
who can remember these things
[Music]
that's awesome
it's so funny
yeah uh so
whatever
nobody wants to help me put this
together thank you
it's good you don't hang out with
yourself crazy too this is just an exact
representation of Jeffrey you know what
sucks it's like Jeffrey will always be
successful and he'll always keep going
and he's like an actual bad person like
he's an actual bad person and it's
evident by these people like it comes
out in them and I'm just like God it
sucks
he's an awful person he's violent you
told me he's told you that he thinks
he's vile yeah and then he the same on
the podcast and I the least he could
have done is like you know what let's
just delete that podcast it's still up
it's like I don't expect you to defriend
him he's that's your cash cow that's
where you're getting your money it's not
sure you're defending him Jeffrey never
he's like he was worth me a different
entertainment in fact now he's a DJ but
anyway he's like oh you don't remember
what you said about me now that's funny
man I mean he had a clip of her
downplaying just I feel ending makes me
feel some type of way because I was
sitting right next to her now I have
looked pretty hard to try he didn't look
that hard
everyone was bored and people
entertained her lies it was so horrible
for my mental health and it says you
don't remember
that's crazy she don't remember
oh but she has a kid now she's healed no
she's awful she's but I'm more worried
about the taser thing did he ever answer
to that
the taser ambient
that's pretty spicy sounds like he paid
some money to just make it go away
jeez 45k huh that's all it takes to bury
something like that how did that come
out before the 5K what I'm curious how
that came out
because it was on it was on the uh it
was on their taxes on the street because
they did it as a as a deductible oh
really
the Cosmetic Company is who paid it so
it was on there he did that he did the
hush money as a business expense huh
interesting private companies all tax
returns public because they wouldn't
that wouldn't I don't think so no that
wouldn't make sense yeah that's true I
don't know publicly I don't think it's
public
well somebody sent it to him right yeah
you know they probably wasn't tax
returns it was Pro like a public company
or something well I don't think it's
trade publicly traded
oh speaking of which you know the the
cast media scam we were talking about
this guy that over all the
podcasters and then they joined um
podcast one and it was all about this
big IPL
so let's check their I they stick their
stock price what is IPO again it's a
initial public offering when you join
the stock exchange
so let's see how's it going for uh damn
not great star
40 down I mean they got a leg up on FaZe
wait what is it Courtside group it's
probably their parent org I just type
podcast One stock
I'm sure it's just their parent company
no cleanup look at their their thing as
pod C
so embarrassing to make take a podcast
company public like bro it's not that
serious
you know what I mean you literally just
do ad deals stop it right
well from what I understand they do a
little bit more than that right because
they actually think so
yeah maybe they're a parent company when
they build Studios space yeah I think
that they they do
I mean in coffee's video uh they explain
how like a lot of these podcasters were
on like a retainer with this company
like they got paid monthly by them
regardless so and so how is a little bit
more work for them yeah I mean saying
your business is not that serious bro
trying to go public with it some silly
right you're talking about cast by
the way not podcast one I don't know
what the they do cast
yeah I mean that that um that video was
real interesting because obviously I
have a
a pretty good insight into the podcast
World being set
a podcast actually let me pull it up now
because there was this conversation
here
specifically so he gets this guy the
owner four million dollars uh calling
something he's the owner of this company
who everybody out and the actually
the amount of people that he over
is crazy like I keep getting transient
DMS from people I keep hearing about
people huh and he was yeah you're right
he was giving people these crazy uh
minimum guarantees but I think he must
have known that that was never feasible
he was literally just collecting money
right he was getting as many people to
come and getting collecting as much
money as possible the year that he went
bankrupt and didn't pay people he bought
like a two million dollar house nice
you know what I mean oh and then the
best part is that coffee found out that
right before they filed for bankruptcy
he moved his assets into a
to a uh a trust that's like specifically
for hiding your assets nice with the law
firms that their tagline is we do asset
retention nothing else nice they
literally say that you want a specialist
it's pretty great
now you know
um I wanted to talk with you because I I
appreciate the work that's such a funny
I appreciate the your journalistic
integrity and I know that you're trying
to butter them up like all of them cast
is sort of the dream of of what do
people agree vision of Independence you
know I think they they they they think
that they
do they not have persuasive they don't
have lawyers I mean cavcat wanted to
come on our show
these people they think they're
persuasive got it
they they really think that they have
some kind of attack
that they're better
but it's so transparent I mean listen to
this idiot Free Speech not bound
by sort of corporate Norms
um the ability and the backbound
backbone to support Visionary talented
unique like the idea of this company
going bankrupt is truly mind-bending he
does nothing except sign deals and
taking money how do you go bankrupt
there's lit there's not even overhead
anyway whatever maybe I'm a two in the
baseball but it's interesting video I'd
watch it
thanks
thank you
all right you're done with your painting
should we do it maybe we should do the
painting stuff now yeah
sure
oh I want to do red flag green flags too
are we hungry
I guess maybe I don't know what are you
thinking about
I'm not really but I'll eat I'll eat
I'll eat
you know me I'll eat
you guys hungry yeah okay yeah love love
is always up for a talk yeah
what are you feeling
I don't actually know I just feel like
I'm getting hungry and it happens
quickly you feel it and then like you
feel like anything
no
any suggestions is there any rectangular
Foods we can think of it is
maybe some latkes that's round bro I
don't with circle there's some new
Taco Bell there's a new Taco Bell item
that's quite delicious a new item it's
like a taquitos or whatever it's called
okay
yeah
rectangles they're delicious if you look
at it from the top yeah maybe I mean I
know it's a it's a cylinder let's be
real but you flatten it to two
Dimensions if you're in a
two-dimensional world right it's
rectangular if you unroll the it too
that's a pretty good point let's do it
and that there is like a conceit that we
are operating in a two-dimensional
mindset here because I mean he's naming
all rectangle circles these are
two-dimensional shapes great point right
we're only existing in the same plane as
him I don't know
when did you see the pigment
that's pretty funny you want a new water
I have my bottom yeah we'll get you a
new one
um well also I've heard theories that uh
we're actually do live in a
two-dimensional world and the reality is
merely a hologram I don't know what that
means but I'm sort of projection that
makes sense into a higher point it does
but um actually yeah hug some ass dude
all the Israelis
thing
it's just kind of weird you know those
of us smart enough to understand it it's
just I remember seeing that on the cover
of like a science journal magazine and I
was like the
I don't even get that oh uh
speaking of two-dimensional the jalapeno
dip at Taco Bell is the best sauce ever
yellow yellow Vino yeah there's a yellow
pine or something oh jalapeno yeah yeah
I like literally didn't know what you
were saying it's so jalapeno you've
never tried it it's better than
Chick-fil-A sauce
people won't know what you're saying if
you say it say like that yeah what do
you eat it with jalapeno no yellow Pinot
I just read it how it's spelled well in
Spanish it's a Mexican
uh I guess it's a Mexican ingredient I
don't know yeah but yeah Spanish it's
jalapeno what do you eat it when
uh the Taquito the Taquito the Taquito
in the yellow but you know in the I I'm
thinking
and other parts where there's less
Mexicans they call it jalapeno
ideas I think they actually do call it
jalapeno
good old jalapeno they call them rolled
chicken tacos on the menu why don't they
call them taquitos just own it
why is it gotta be a rolled chicken taco
guys it's a new dish all right so you
want fabula yeah all right
extra rectangular please yeah
Tang you learn
tune your remix is awesome that play it
play I want to listen
[Music]
all right
that is so funny
[Music]
when did you make that I think the
before we even watch the video because
we were oh really we were just um we
were just singing in the office oh
that's awesome
add that in the can add it that's
awesome man there you go see Zach's
already thinking three steps ahead and
watch the damn video there we go dude
all right so I guess we're gonna order
talk about that's the segment right now
and then we'll do the painting
people seem to like my haircut and I
love it um thank you I love it I like
the color it just gives like the It
Feels more um familiar yeah familiar but
it looks nice it's very nice thank you I
um all of my ends were so fried
that I had to cut them and it was
actually kind of depressed all week
because I was trying to grow my hair so
bad but I decided to just make it like a
bunch of layers so I don't have to
necessarily make it like really short
all of a sudden again
and so thank you do you want anything
other than the taquitos
[Music]
taco supreme
two one one so to make that three Taco
Supremes
free Taco stream actually
you want a burrito
So you you're getting Dorito you're
getting taquitos and a taco
that's it is the tokido like one or how
much is tequila pack oh it's foreign
we'll get two orders of taquitos here
let me let me do this so between me and
Ela two taquitos with the with the love
dip yum yum that sounds older yeah two
taquitos with love dip
and then three Taco Supremes and then
and then you know I gotta get that Baja
Blast diet
I think I still never had it it's good
do they have Baja Blast slushy
it's racism yeah actually it ruined the
rest of my week right I tried to get
Baja Blast the slushy diet and they
didn't have it pain aha blast diet
and Baja blasts slushy it was the worst
pain I think I have ever felt in my life
have you looked in house and habits
uh Quimby asked this woman is scary she
is now a g Lane Maxwell Stan saying that
Daniel Master syn accuses those Liars
Insanity would love it well she sounds
like a troll I mean
is this a new is this a new Pearl sounds
like someone's just taking the piss no
I'll look at it I'll look at it thanks
for the heads up Quimby I'm gonna look
at it right now I'll tell you right now
if she's a troll if she's for real
I got a good sense for these things you
know what I'm saying
I've been around
I've been around wait to have your
in my mouth oh come on what is this this
is all I see House of habits
four years ago
how do I find it tick tock well let's we
don't have to do it live we'll look into
it Google it
oh it has a lot of caffeine let's do it
live I already had coffee today why not
can we find out how much caffeine's in a
Baja Blast slushie
the goddamn caffeine limit is killing me
well and remember you're not gonna
you're gonna drink like a quarter of
that yeah yeah
around
54 milligrams that's like a cup right or
less than a cup of cups usually a cup of
coffee has 80 to 100 so that's like a
can of sodi yeah okay and the whole
thing and I don't drink yeah I think
it's fine then yeah here I found them
here's a post where they're sad that he
got 30 years are they just an Instagram
account
uh yeah they have 1.2 million followers
but so does Jimmy Lee so
she has 15 000 likes a little more
engagement which she doesn't have any
social media issues with uh
it's the best we love her
1844 girl we love you
so
close enough
88-14 what is it
it's like the Neo-Nazi uh tagline What
is it 1488 1488 yeah that's what I said
no it isn't it 1488
it's 14.
someone said Baja Blast my Baja busy
that's inappropriate don't say that not
in this chat damn
let's clean it up please let's clean it
up
oh everyone wants to talk about swoop uh
we'll talk about it on Monday because
that video is way too long uh we tried
watching it last night but it's so long
really long I finished four hours I want
to do it I want to do it right I want to
tell Josh's story properly just give me
the highlights you know what I mean yeah
one one night
just give me the weekend and I I think
I will tell his story and I will do it
justice thank you
thank you so much and also hopefully we
can maybe get him because before
he was talking about it he had tweeted
out that maybe after yeah I'd like to
talk to him I always have questions you
know so with all that being said let's
do our painting let's do it let's get
right into it it's age three presents
a segment of the Arts I myself am an
angel Patron
which is why I invest in the Arts
I bought all these easels all of these
canvases of course they were forced to
paint me in celebration of my angelness
so uh in prep let's go ahead and roll
just to set the tone a little bit here
to let you guys know what happened so
oh we're getting a one sec are we ready
in one sec we're getting a once one sec
here we go hold it just hold it hold it
hold it go ahead roll it
welcome everybody to H3 art Corner last
time we did our corner it was a big hit
we did the sculptures everyone did a
sculpture and it said a lot about who
they are as people it was a real glimpse
into in some cases the Artistry and in
other cases The psychosis of some of the
people on the crew so today I have we're
doing a live modeling session that's me
attempting to do the pose of rose from
the Titanic the French like the French
girls yada yada so everybody will be uh
doing their interpretation of me laid
out like this Dan has already captured
several upskirts it's making me
uncomfortable Everybody Must delete
these photos after the session thank you
we've got brushes we have got palette
knives we are using real artist palettes
to mix our paint
and look at this beautiful
array of colors
and what is this cream and what is this
orange and perhaps what is this
Brown
does everyone know how to mix to make
certain colors
um how do you make hot pink
oh my God light pink
anyways red and white let's go crazy
what are you getting for Amber maybe I'm
sorry you're distracting you when you're
rubbing your stomach what is it sorry
what are you getting for your Amber my
Amber eye colors oh uh amber there's
some red and oranges I'm gonna grab
Brown for that I have much more than
brown in my eyes I'll have you know my
mom will kill you we got
anything fun for tomorrow yeah
oh this is for tomorrow yeah
that is fun I'm getting started here um
I'm thinking I'm making the penis table
at first and I'm using this as a little
bit of a guideline stay tuned the Amber
eyes
starting with the eyes
they're the window to the soul they're
the window to the soul
starting with during an interesting
choice
you gotta get the foundation first
yep
what was this there's checking the wind
direction yeah where the how the paint's
gonna we're inside there's no Breeze
if I see hot in here this is a red hot
image turquoise turquoise orange
magentas I'm gonna go for kind of like a
for Cosmic Vibe you know we're gonna get
we're getting a little weird with it
today I'm gonna be honest I've never
been good at painting I've always been
better at digital stuff working with a
handicap right now but yeah but I'll do
my best
all right
[Music]
you're feeling some confident
oh not yet but I will I'll feel good
soon I'm trying to get his little
pointed toes right now
horribly I hate this I'm doing
so bad bro
no it can't be that bad it's horrible
but I don't know it's just getting
started so yeah I see right as he draws
the Masterpiece no the same thing
look at I'm over here paying Yo Gabba
Gabba dude and I gotta hear from him
left and right because my left hand gets
tired sometimes so I'm switching over
just on it bro it sucks I'm older how
are you feeling Ethan sleepy my arm is
dying this is very uncomfortable from
this arm specifically dude I knew a kid
in a high school he passed out from
being blackout drunk in a weird position
on his leg and his leg like
never worked again the same way like he
got permanent damage so hopefully no
permanent damage here
oh
nice
I suffer for the art clearly yeah my arm
I put it great I don't know they were
actually painting you while you were
there yeah live model wow yep it must be
so hard for your arm yeah it knows it
was hard I went home and I nursed it but
I'm okay thanks for your concern cam I'm
100 now
oh good now we showed cam because he
started over
[Music]
right what happened Kim were you happy
with your that wasn't bad by
alliteration yeah it was kind of nice
yeah
I mean you'll see I kind of want to
throw you guys off by showing what I
made because I did start over but you'll
see okay so okay okay I like it a castle
so is yours up here now elar is it no
it's not I saw you I'll just leave it
yeah I'll leave it separate all right so
like last time
these are scrambled in
in order and we will reveal them one by
one
an attempt to
identify the artists
what's this
so Dan our uh our curator
let us begin with painting number one
all right
oh my goodness
oh nice curvy uh you captured my curves
yeah
gorgeous
I'll tell you something it's giving
Olivia and I'll tell you why it's the
stars in the sky
because she's a star in the sky
it's giving it's giving Olivia what do
you think I was thinking Sam Sam yeah
I don't know why clearly there's some
there's some good Artistry here yeah
there's like uh interesting
interpretation of the the pillows the
colorful pillows and I actually did a
sick job on the Stars too yeah
also it could be cam though and I'll
tell you why it could definitely be Kim
because he did the same exact color
variant in the sky that's true is that
the one that he bailed on right
okay wait hold on let me take a look at
that
so good
it's pretty good though yeah
beautiful I love it so what do you what
do we think do we have to say now or do
we see the rest no we don't have to say
no okay
some people are saying Lena
for some reason they just feeling that
all right AB uh uh curator Dan please to
the next painting
[Music]
[Laughter]
the
ing
is that what you see when you see me
that's epic dead
you wanted to die I don't understand
what's the message here you you can't
wait for me to die no
whoever Drew this wants me dead no I
don't think so it's just
um they see through
the the obvious layer that we all look
at they're just it's just a deeper
person
that's not what I see I see this take
this as a threat
okay interesting
uh
let's move through and then we'll unless
you wanna I say it's for sure again Well
he kind of made it a little too
obviously yeah breaking the elbow
or the river oh there's a yeah
[Laughter]
I didn't even notice that
that'd be it could be to throw us off
but it's not that's Cam yeah
okay
Wow Let's Get a look at this
okay now what I like is things yeah
don't even mean as someone who doesn't
have a ton of artistic ability
I feel like they really did try and I
feel like that because of Ian's comments
saying I'm doing yoga bagaba here this
is giving me that oh
interesting I wonder if it's Ian some
are saying Zach I think Zacks will be
more demented
more disturbing
but I like what I'm seeing sure it's
gorgeous and it captures my weird
flexible fake arms and elbows very good
I have a rounded elbow
why did you all choose for the pink sky
because there was like a painting there
there was a pink painting yeah it was a
we used to backdrop
behind it yeah wait should we did we
show the original picture
like that
yeah
you can open it I guess in this oh yeah
absolutely uh let's see let me
I don't have it under this thinking
Discord if you go up to the beginning
[Music]
I'm gonna resend it
well just are you going up too much
just put it in Discord please okay yeah
somebody had um everyone had different
the other picture shows the painting so
we can
I see it's the background
everybody had a different perspective
like Dan had a really up one he
was just looking up at me different
perspectives
you know garyvee
does it gonna give away yours
yeah
you know where I was
look at that man you wake up first thing
in the morning okay I like it Picasso
he's in your bed what do you do
I'm asking you what do you do
you say Hi how are you say good morning
here's another perspective this was
probably what like cams right
I can't wait to have your in my
mouth oh come on bro that's not cool
Dan's I actually haven't seen dance but
I imagine it's crazy yeah how do you
even like I don't think even the most
talented artists couldn't really make
that look like anything yeah that's
crazy that's not fair
that's just nuts
oh that's a disaster look at that beard
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right so um
up next
our next artist
[Music]
oh
whoa
this was giving like Picasso kind of
like intentional beautiful brush strokes
this could be Elena this is Master Level
pure graze too yeah
thick body
let me see the whole thing uh AV zoom
out a little bit so thick
I'm liking what I'm what I'm seeing here
what I'm feeling
I feel like Lena's um sculpture of you
had
had similar Vibe with the brush Strokes
um
the genius the Artistry kind of looks
like vacation Santa
I do look very chill there yeah yeah
I want to beat that guy when you grow up
yeah
I want to be him now
[Music]
okay very good
I don't know
not really or while Ela thinks Lena
do we have a
like a
board to move them the
okay
[Music]
what the oh
what am I looking at hmm dude why is
this top down who's on nobody's on top
of me
this is like God's eye
let me zoom in on the face
what the
holy crap
oh yeah is this a Zach it's kind of
reminding me the face from Zach's
sculpture it's hard to say I'll have to
see the other ones before I can see this
one is Zach and which one's not
that is interesting and I sure love the
I mean creative juices were flowing
clearly
wow
very good
[Music]
oh that's then
that's gonna be there
I think you did pretty good with what
yeah
if assuming that is yours it's not bad I
like the outline wait why does it why do
I look like a body outline
what do you chalk my dead corpse another
one
it's just like a cool interpretation no
he's got the white outline around my
body that's what they do with dead
bodies I believe crime scenes but it's
an outline also for the pillow it's not
just your body yeah that's evidence too
two of you guys want me dead
okay that's Dan right yeah sure
[Music]
what come on what happened somebody was
really not feeling their face huh
that's Zack
exactly couldn't nail the face down
[Music]
so let's take a look here let's
appreciate the artistry
let's appreciate for a moment what's
going on with my knee what's that what's
going on with the little feet
I had saw I was wearing socks
I mean Olivia did make a comment about
you think that shows my pointy feet is
she the only is that the only one that
shows my feet
um so far it might be a tell my
[Music]
mom could be a tell
sometimes things change too true it
reminds me this is this really is a a
kind of a beautiful piece though it
reminds me there's this one Mexican
artist that makes these really beautiful
paintings of fat people
hmm
let me pull that up Picasso I think I
would be a really good subject for him I
type Mexican artist that paints fat
people and they found it
this guy
[Music]
he's so he's legit
he's legit so good everything is I love
that for no reason
I love it that's happening he's a skinny
Legend of course
so it's giving me this you know and the
body type yeah you know here's a fat
little family okay his name is Fernando
botero
yeah he's fat really interesting shout
out
how much days are cool
self-portrait
yeah here's the Mona Lisa fat
here's the whole thing
the Mona Lisa about that
I like that what's he trying to say do
you think
what are we saying with the fat people
that's just how he sees the world maybe
he has already dysmorphia see fat people
[Music]
true also true right it's kind of like
and
um Spirited Away how did
these are these are working class or I
don't know
were they considered uh
higher class
he might be a Spanish artist actually he
wait why people are saying he just died
today he just died today at 91. yeah
what are the chances of that so Cosmic
he's Colombian excuse me
wait a minute can we firm that no that
was insane just confirmed it yes
I have never talked about this guy in my
whole life
through you dude oh my God that's crazy
what that's so Cosmic dude
how old was he how did he die 91. oh
good ass life good long life there
and how well you don't even really need
to know how he died at 91 that's crazy
what the
no no nothing
the daily maybe nothing we listened
literally nothing Biden getting impaired
I didn't even know I didn't know what
his name was he had uh pneumonia
yeah I mean a 91 uh a pretzel
will kill you
a hard breath song that's true
[Music]
oh my God that's such a crazy
coincidence I'll go check him out he
really is uh there's no same thing as a
coincidence
I love these paintings the spirit lives
on through whoever painted Ethan
thank you shout out for elgos the ghost
possessed whoever painted that
yeah he's he's really good right
I the reason I thought he was Mexican is
because whenever I went to Mexico for
some reason I always saw his art there
and I never saw it anywhere else so
I made that assumption
[Music]
how did you know I swear to God I looked
in the window I just saw wine
[Music]
wow that's so weird
damn well anyway
yeah
[Music]
what the hell whoa
is this a painting is this all a
painting whoa
wow gorgeous it's so detailed that okay
so I think that that's gotta be Sam then
it is so detailed because we know that
Sam spent a lot of time somebody spent a
lot of time on this oh my goodness Jesus
look at the Artistry let me know what
the Dan
so beautiful
oh my God you're here you too yeah it's
you I can tell it's you
let me see the whole thing yeah the bins
with the shelves I'm trying to remember
who was standing there that's crazy
maybe that shouldn't do that that looks
really good just the pillow closest on
the right is such shade well shaded yeah
and the white is that light coming from
the room
oh yeah
[Music]
that's crazy
Sun Beams you guys
even got my sodi can on the table Yeah
my phone my soda can this is a very
literal interpretation
let me see hey
it was labels on the boxes
okay who would
so here's what I think it's Sam because
she loves putting time into these arts
and she messaged last night late saying
I'm still working on it so but I'm
trying to remember where she was
so here's another interesting okay all
right because Sam you were you weren't
there at the time right are you where
you oh you were she was in the video you
set it up right you were there you set
it up
[Laughter]
you were there
I remember that
you guys I have to my memory doesn't
work like at all no no it works but it
works usually better than mine selective
it it's it's all kind of blurred
together
into one hazy
um all time is just one it's one with
you
okay well we're gonna say that we think
that's Sam I want a print of that we
have one more and and really
congratulations Sam yeah it's so good
last one last one
oh
another God's eye view
oh my God I'm chilling Cedar Rapids oh
look at the sharks sharks
I'm just chilling and
of y'all want
[Music]
y'all want me who would do that wow who
would go that right who's thinking about
the beach right now
right somebody wants to be on the beach
yeah
[Music]
all right let's go through we gotta we
got to assign these
so let's go back to the beginning now
we've just we had suspicions about this
one
okay
it's not cam we know that
but there's some beautiful Artistry here
these are all so beautiful and and the
difference in all of them is really cool
I feel that whoever painted this doesn't
hate me it's opened it maybe you are
your initial oh no what'd you say
oh Dan was talking about the mic he's
got a handheld open okay you said
initially that you thought it was Olivia
I did yeah I thought it was Olivia
because of the Stars I do wonder if it's
Olivia it's very like uh yeah it's
giving exactly that's true Olivia and I
do think that whoever Drew this light
does like me and like as a person
which is obviously not the case for all
of these which we'll go through
so I'm willing to say Olivia right we
have that you like me right
yeah I think so right we enjoy
a little Rapport going yeah
okay so let's say Olivia on that one
okay A friend Drew that do we want to uh
a friend Drew that yeah do we want to
reveal them as we go or do you want to
go all the way to the end no let's go to
the end okay so yeah calling this one
Olivia for now
giveaway quick quickly agree on the cam
there okay
next up
um so this one I don't think this person
hates me I think they hate themselves
laughs
you know which kind of goes with my Ian
suspicion you think that speaks to Ian
yeah the self-loathing
let me see let me see a shot of this
but Ian does have some artistic well
there's some Artistry here kind of like
in the Torso the body kind of hits
right I'd say everything but the the
neck is pretty yeah
a Luffy arm right right do that do that
for me damn where you cut the arm and
head yeah see that's pretty good yeah
that's a decent perspective yeah but but
you know heads and hands that's that's
where the art is yeah
that's great and EM did just watch um
one piece so
yes I did what'd you think oh a lot of
people are guessing a B on this one that
was great you liked it it was good right
yeah I'm excited for the next oh I'll
tell you uh something about the one
piece apparently they wrote the whole
second season already before the strike
also going to be able to shoot like when
the strike is in they can start when
that construct ends yeah interesting
okay so that I thought that was
interesting so people think it's a b
that is actually that is potentially
good too there's a fair bit of
self-loathing in ab's Psycho a psyche is
that right Abe a little bit I don't see
this one as a b
it could be well where's Zach's then
Zacks has got to be the the message yeah
no I think Zacks is the Colombian
um the artist who passed today oh that
one the chunky okay that could be Zack
he gave up on the face yeah I can see
that
yeah he just was nah
okay so so we're gonna have to decide I
think we have Zach I think it's there
then
the third one let's go to there that's
the one we're on the third one this one
I truly it's gonna be Ian or Zach for me
yeah if we can't identify all of them so
this last one would be a b if it's not
that one oh that's a good guess that is
an A B kind of thing huh because he
loves me he wants me to be happy but he
also wants he also resents me a little
bit and that's why he put the sharks
he's always worried about you maybe
that's why the sharks are there he's
worried about me yeah
there's a lot going on he knows about
the the dangers of the world I think
you're right that's a b yeah then if we
go to the third one we're gonna say
a process of elimination it sounds like
you think this one's uh
I don't think it's Ian um
which other one could be Ian so I think
the Ian could potentially be the red the
truck outline and Ian hates me he wants
me dead that's why he drew me as a
chocolate so if that was Ian
Dan oh we know which one is dance
do you know that
yes
right we thought that one's there could
the third one be done
that wasn't no because Dan no Dan had
the upskirt yeah
we know Sam for sure Ian was next to me
and it was next to you
so he's pretty much working on an
upskirt as well it was a big there was a
big wide angle between the two of you
yeah that's Sam that's a B I feel
confident and then that's that could be
the beautiful curvy one is Zach
uh-huh
somebody you haven't really mentioned at
all in your speculation is love yeah
love is here wait so did everybody do
one yeah and Lena Love is a bit of a
wild card
I haven't seen him participate is there
one for love here yeah love Sarah
I'm here there's always room for love I
know but I thought it was already all
accounted for hmm
okay oh so maybe that one is love the
the green yeah that one wait that could
be Dan
that's also an upskirt wait I think I
know that's Dan
okay and then the one that I thought was
Ian is Ian the outline the chalk outline
because Ian does want me dead
uh so which one oh so maybe love is the
oh that could be
loved balloon the chimpa Loompa and I am
wrapped up like a little Taco Bell
Taquito
are you saying this one I love no the
next to it the third one you're saying
This is Love yeah go ahead and slap a
love post it on there
and then how about this next one well
then there's only one person I had a I
had a feeling that the next one is
Leonard do you agree yeah
and like you said the brush Strokes the
artists intention yeah she's got a style
she sees me she also a little bit wants
me dead is it
and not in like a bad we're not in like
a mean way it's just she's tired
we put her through a lot I to me that
one is like a peek into your future
because I'm old you're retired I'm
saying she wants me to retire she's
older she's like I've been down with it
she wants Freedom okay yeah
and so then that's Lena okay
so you're saying that's then and again
that symbolizes mine and Dan's
relationships a little chaotic it's a
little of a interesting and at the end
of the day Dan doesn't know how he feels
about me okay that's kind of what this
represents uncertainty yeah okay okay
and then you're saying this is Ian Ian
we're talking about mine wow the most
hate I would have never thought that
that's Ian but I'm following your lead
here okay
and that just leaves us uh wait who does
that leave us that one's that oh that
one's that so Zach right yeah okay so we
have guesses for everybody everybody now
I wanted to make a comment y'all thought
it would be so obvious like you're oh
you're gonna know exactly which is mine
but well I was thinking that because you
were there you would remember where
everybody's perspective was but I forgot
that you your memory is terrible and
that you forget everything I'm I'm
trying not to think about it like that
because I don't want to cheat no I I
think you know I think we had a robust
debate here I was trying not to uh
remember that and not think about it not
pay attention to the detail yeah
all right
reveal and also knowing that you guys
aren't exactly Rembrandt and it's not
going to be totally uh proportional I
think that's fair that's fair all right
so no offense and untaken so the guest
here was Olivia can the real painter
please speak up
yeah
oh girl you shine bright like shine on
every damn day I love it all right so
moving down
here we guess cam can the real painter
of this one please speak up I mean you
knew I mean yeah I will say you kind of
gave it away yeah I mean the frustration
wasn't
like the dark nature of it wasn't with
you it's more that my arm's broken I was
struggling to paint so I just kind of
okay it's really good yeah it looks good
I like it and I put a little bit of
myself into it in the arm there
uh and then next up we have this one
which the guest was love can the real
painter please speak up
it's me
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't but apparently you think I hate
myself no this is probably just by the
painting
now I can totally change my opinion
oh man holy smoke I did not expect that
and then uh next up so this one you have
Gus Lina
yeah
so can the actual painter of this one
please speak up
that's right here that's me that's the
Yo Gabba Gabba that's the Yo Gabba Gabba
so I like this what do you think about
my psyche now yeah I think that you now
want to retire and that actually you
can't wait for me just to stop doing
this show so you can continue your life
it's a little self-insertion
but Ian always has a little flare of
artistry and this you can see the you
know the the brush marks what's your
what was your perspective here Ian I
just finished the van Gogh Lego set
that was a good one it's a good deal
yeah yeah wow I see the info Van Gogh
Lego set is that a real thing yeah what
is that what is that that's in it yeah
Starry Night
yeah
self-portrait and Starry Night
oh oh what that's it that's crazy
can y'all please just let me look damn
okay gee you Lego
that's actually super sick that's cool
okay there you go
a fan of the Arts a student of the Arts
all right uh next up we have this one
which you guessed was me
can the real
painter speak up
how you doing
oh God we got them all wrong you ain't
Joker right now well here's but that
doesn't make Zach where were you
standing well okay so Sam sent me a
picture and I got that cross right you
weren't sure he wasn't he was the one
that wasn't there so I was home and I
was listening to
um a lot of Iron Butterfly like in a
Gotta Devita you know so that's what
this painting is called in-a-gadda
Devita oh and why what's the
relationship in the Garden of Eden
in the Garden of Eden
and what's going on so this is supposed
to be it's abstract Eden it's beautiful
in the garden yeah everything yes you
know respected appreciate it yeah a joke
was the Joker color palette intentional
um I wanted some texture you know I'm an
artist artiste excuse me but the purple
and the green is specifically I had like
three colors to work with
and how long did you spend on this ah it
took me a couple hours really yeah
that's fascinating oh is it why why do
you say that no I can totally see all
the effort that went into this yeah
uh-huh I bet you're sweet ass either
Zach what's this right here shadow
and then that line is like your foot
that's like on your leg and then it's
like right that's your like crease and
your thigh
very good yeah your balls may or may not
be hanging out I don't know
really yeah well they weren't just to be
clear they were not in the photo they
were not in the photos
okay all right so next up we have this
one which uh originally had Ian's thing
on there so can the real painter speak
up yes me oh
yeah then I talked you out of it
yes yeah I mean if you pull up that
photo that I had again it was just such
a like the photo was it was impossible
honestly it's like an abstract like
shape your body was like you know very
odd looking and uh so I just started
someone wanted to take it back at
drawing this at home I'd like to see
that was not fair there's no way to draw
this like look at the mid like your
torso like obviously like it's just the
perspective that's making it look weird
but like this is such an odd like
nebulous shape here the fact that our
brains can even process this and know
it's a person
AI you're totally right yeah I wouldn't
know what to make of this yeah
[Music]
I did
yeah look at that handsome devil
well well done it is it is very uh
artistic and interesting
all right next up we have this one which
uh the guest was uh
so now you're saying This Must Be Love
must be like all right can the real uh
painter of this one please speak up
[Music]
wait what the was that did you did
you just turn the camera around yeah
okay
you're it's not like you to um take a
shortcut oh yeah no no I tried I just
messed up at the face I left it so you
could see how it looked
red eyes I was trying to give you your
Amber eyes and then and it just holy it
didn't look right
that's the morning I thought we were
cool
we hide it I like the mixed media though
you know yeah yeah it's interesting but
you know did you get were you inspired
by uh the Colombian artists absolutely
absolutely I see that rest in peace
rip to the absolute go again all right
so next up we have this one I mean at
least got to be right about Sam yeah I
mean the real artist please speak up
together
I got a whole handle this this uh Beast
look at this gorgeous gorgeous oh yeah
oh yeah that's so good it's all there
that's really hard there to get so much
detail in there I truly would buy a
print of that yeah you also have a
really weird angle yeah that's a really
weird angle too yeah it was a it would
send the reference
yeah I got the white like directly in my
oh it's the round lights that we have we
should we should for sure you know how
Seinfeld has like super prolific merch
of like the Kramer painting oh yeah and
a goldfish I can sell this
well done Sam yeah that only leaves one
person so I guess this one's obvious
this one is love that's mean oh that's
love
and he's he's our Island boy being from
Sweden was that what it was the island
boy nod what was the beach that's like
that's your life on the beach there and
all these dangers looming around you but
you're pretty but you're chilling and
you're chilling
you know
the sharks are there but I don't fear
that they're there but you're just
chilling you're just chilling you're
just vibing on the beach
okay you like that wow am I in a raft or
I'm on a beach beach it sounds like a
desert island I thought it was on a rat
yeah it's like a little little beach
okay you got the crabs there really no
crap well I I I yeah I mean it's a
really small island yeah it's a tiny
Island
and do we want to reveal elas
[Music]
I was eyeing this and I'm like God damn
did this like
[Music]
wow that number one podcast
number one baby it's number one pod host
there we go that's awesome
what is the blue color telling us
um nothing really
I didn't mean anything
well you got it well I think that
there's it from nothing I think there's
there is an underlying sadness to Ethan
you know
well there's there is truly I mean with
like Picasso's blue era yeah it looks
like I'm definitely in my Shredder blue
era right right
and you also yeah yeah the blue we share
the color blue yeah I I am blue okay
come on everybody thank you thank you
yes everybody did a fantastic job thank
you it was fun
did we vote for a winner last time but
there were all winners we really all
yeah we do yeah it's hard it's
subjective who can say who can say who
knows obviously obviously it's there
it's Sam
I don't know though maybe it would be
we did do it last time it is kind of
interesting because
yeah with the bus we did
it is kind of interesting just to see
where people's heads are at
let's do that I love the difference
let's do the straw poll with all of them
just to just if this isn't winner okay
because we're always which one is your
favorite yeah which is your favorite
straw poll yeah give me a minute I'll
set up
maybe maybe get your camera again so we
can do one pass over them once I put up
the pole to remind people all right
everybody get your voting fingers ready
your favorite crazy
you can just hold it when it comes by
you're gonna hold yours when it comes by
if I'm gonna put that one back
just for consistency
you captured that face like perfect yeah
it's so good so impressed
thank you Eva I think I look more
handsome there which is nice okay so
Olivia thank you and then cam
and here we have Lena
good job on the body Lena this is Ian
thank you thank you
[Music]
Zach Joker brain
that's me
uh that's a b
good job on the body maybe and then we
have some Sam Samantha
love
[Music]
and Ela
fantastic wow
wow all right so I'm creating this Pole
right now well I was wondering if you're
gonna try to do like um accurate skin
tone because I know all the Masters they
start with blue right you can yeah but I
didn't feel like it yeah it's a lot of
work
to do all that mm-hmm
well there it is
uh let's get the uh votes in Dan is
putting the pole together and we've got
a lot of fantastic show left guys here
on this beautiful gorgeous Friday
afternoon
oops I was muted I just put the poll in
the chat and pinned it at the top so if
you could go to a straw poll
at the top and let us know what's your
favorite is I don't see it pinned I see
that you just posted it once oh there it
is there it is
all right everybody else uh flowing in
here let me uh give it a second before I
put it up
[Music]
okay
okay oh somebody in the office already
voted responses here that's funny so it
looks like Sam is taking a good 26 ish
27 filed closely by Ela cam Olivia Ian
Dan damn Lena's getting murdered here
well like you said art is objective
avian Lena took the fat L on this one
watch them go up now
I'm we're actually yeah I'm rooting for
you guys it is going up now there you go
Zach is actually well this Zach is great
I mean he's doing great appreciate it
pal love is doing great Dan you know
doing great when doing these things like
painting and doing the bust I enjoy that
a lot yeah it's fun it's so
relaxing
it is relaxing yeah well we used to do
that like every day in school and
then you just stop yeah you know slow
used to be a big part of our life
we were so in the zone yesterday
painting I feel like for a good 30
minutes it was silent everyone was just
like working away it was really fun that
was nice I napped a little bit these are
my favorite episodes I love these little
yeah it's really fun
so it's actually quite close between Sam
and Nila but Sam is up four percent for
uh you know a modern day man give it up
give it up she put in the time well
deserved danila is uh performed quite
well as well congratulations to you guys
uh
Kim's threat of uh eliminating me it
took place in third congratulations to
that
I think what Cam's saying is I'm gonna
break your arms so you know how it feels
Olivia with the star power we love it
girl shine on
chime like a diamond you as well girl
Ian's uh beautiful artistic Picasso
inspired
coming in Van Gogh but yeah if you
prevent gum right
and uh lean actually took a bit of a
jump she's not in last anymore Abe they
they saved that spot for you nice
[Applause]
now Zach's in second it's really a the
real race is happening here at the
bottom three all right
loves taking a commanding lead of the
bottom
uh before thank you guys
although damn it that that far ahead
either it's really interesting down here
the bottom five
but I think I think it's done shaking
out there we can call it a day thank you
everybody thank you thank you
very good very good fantastic
truly remarkable
truly inspiring and fantastic
Let's see we got all kinds of good stuff
left
um
xqc getting slammed in the head with the
soccer ball
is that very funny
let's check it out real fast
xqc was truly keeping us in the game
who's putting his whole body on the line
keeping his face oh God that looks
really oh yeah that's why I don't
play sports
is so pretty I said he's so brave
he is so brave he took it quite well he
did and he got up so quick
that looked like it hurt let's be honest
this cannot be real Elizabeth home
the prolific scammer who owned uh
that blood company what was it was like
the biggest Serranos theranos is now
friends with Jen Shaw in prison this
can't be what happened is too powerful
don't let these two women meet Dude the
world isn't ready oh my God they're
gonna start a business together from
prison what was the shambia that they
both do
I wonder fill your blood healing your
blood they're gonna be the people that's
the only thing
they just don't say where it comes from
Elizabeth Holmes and Jen Shaw become
friends in prison people reports they're
friends they're both rehabilitating and
have bonded over being on this journey
of positive change yeah the situations
brought them together and they have a
good understanding of one another
they're getting through it together who
the released that statement
just as a rep
golly man
they're both like really nasty criminals
and both of them probably have also
socked away a few million
so they might go out and just be besties
and have fun you know go straight in
their their Louis Vuittons yeah
wow what a pairing
what a pairing
what do they do what do you think they
do for fun they play cards
they talk to people for commentary
um
wonder if they can be like we're super
honest with you talk about how they're
innocent you think they just do that or
are they super honest about their crimes
with each other because they're both
I don't know James Sean's in such denial
like watching her on the show he pleaded
crazy though because she had no choice
it's not true but I mean
what else could she have done well if
she was really she was kept saying she
was going to go to trial she was going
to go to trial yeah she's going she's
gone for that
he was paying those lawyers a ton of
money she was ready yeah and she was
crying about that on the show about how
much money it was costing
remember she was like talking about
loaning money from her mom
oh God I think she pleaded guilty
because her ass was grass
and she took the plea deal look at this
kind of fire it's kind of a fire fit
okay Orange Is the New sleigh monochrome
like I'm so used to seeing her in this
over the top yeah
ridiculously branded fashion slave stuff
that this is kind of a Vibe I like it
for her
the I feel like the women are better
dressed in prison than the men
what does she have earrings in yeah
that's weird right that they allow her
to have earrings yeah
although they're quite small
can't imagine those being used as a
weapon
just surprising
yep they find ways yeah they're they're
resourceful
she's gonna kill someone in prison I'm
sure of it
so that's a that's an interesting tale
there yeah love that
um okay this is the other game we wanted
to do today which I was very excited
about red flags green flags
we're each going to rate ourselves based
on this chart of how many flags we have
and find out how viable we are
and the sexual Marketplace as uh sexual
Marketplace of ideas
as they might say in the alpha world
how do you rate yourself
so what we did I guess do you wanna
pull up the uh you guys all rated
yourselves ahead of time me and you will
Do's ours separately yeah I think you
guys should go through it
and just kind of we can discuss all of
the red lines so here it is and then
we'll show our results so it's from this
article and they pulled uh people
and asked
if they consider these green flags or
red flags for example
number one green flag
for women and it seems men they read
interesting right that is interesting
number one red flag and women
by far which I love Maga they identify
as Maga isn't that the best absolutely
dude I love women they are the best
absolutely they're just they slay so
hard we should specify this is uh 18 to
34. so this is young people specifically
this is perfect this is I mean this is
the dating age right
they ain't this ain't no Golden Years
right
the saint yo yo grandma's dating site
this is also a green flag they say black
lives matter
red flag they say all lives matter
ladies we love you
so let's go ahead and look at each of
the um uh hit refresh because I just I
added one last one
but now see you guys did this but I'm
curious to know which
well that's why I was we should go
through the chart first
okay so let's do ours yeah okay so first
of all let's go
um green flag
let's see how many green flags we have
based on this
okay but how do you get the chart at the
end
so
so Ethan you would read the left side
and ELO you would read the right
okay huh
just for as far as uh which ones are
directed towards women are left men are
right
yeah but those are the respondents okay
right so I'm on the left you're on the
radio
men it's interesting to see what men
like versus women want two men are
obviously just sucky way suckier and
Lamer across the board
all right here let's do green flag
someone gonna tally this sure I'll tell
you they read so so
frankly I mean I go through spurts of
reading
the men 91 of men think that reading is
a green flag
so you would this applies to you this
site applies to me because women so do
either of you read regularly well what
do you think because
I go through spurts of reading you do
more I unfortunately don't I I don't
have time
I can't find the time
so it's not a green it's not a red flag
but it's a green flag so you're okay
right but what would you say about me I
wouldn't say I'm I mean I read but
like I said it goes through spurts of
Interest I don't know that I can say I'm
a reader I don't like go to bed and read
every night I mean we're like we have
young children it's like I feel like
I'ma say no I'm not a reader you used to
though I mean like I said it comes it
comes in waves okay so so far you're
both Undateable got it so far they say
black lives matter
yeah I say it I say it all I say it
every morning researching researching in
the morning how is this a green flag I
maybe my mind is so because my
dad to me this is I hate this so much
research is for the best deals and rates
before buying
like to me that just makes me feel like
my dad clipping coupons you know
I'm surprised this is such a green flag
for people but do I do that yes I do do
that research for I mean especially if
it's something expensive if it's
something expensive
yeah I do that yeah
so you both get a green flag I guess I
guess sounds like Ela does most the
research
I don't do it as much he sends me the
the honey things do a lot Ethan doesn't
buy anything okay well there you go well
like if I buy something expensive like a
computer or a monitor or something I'll
look around a little bit
I mean who doesn't who does who's just
like this no thought I want this TV I'm
out
no thought
well touch the green flag though I'm not
going to complain
these charts are inverse of each other
so it this same response is on the red
flag one and some amount of some
percentage of people did find this to be
a red flag like if you're researching a
deal that's funny well it sucks there's
a big so like look price matching
something a little bit is fine
it's not a green flag I'm not looking
for it but a red it turns to Red Flag
when it becomes like an obsession and
penny pinching yeah
they say black lives matter every
morning every night
I mean yes yeah yes yeah okay so
rainforward okay so we got some green
flags there they look better in person
what the does that mean
is that what they think I don't know how
to answer that what what kind of what
does that mean it means uh and whose
opinion it means like right well on the
person responding so
it would have to be like you're you had
a picture on a dating profile and they
thought you looked okay and then they
saw you in person they're like oh you
look much better person
but they look better in person of course
that's a green flag who would say no uh
apparently women 50 don't care if they
look and God bless them so there there
was one percent of both men and women
that found that to be a red flag one out
of 100 people see that you look better
in person and they're like I'm out
but I'm actually surprised how low it is
they look better in person only 51
percent of women thought that was good
or a green flag 63 percent of men
thought it was a green I mean
I would
but how do I rate myself that that's
what I'm confused about well do you
think you look better in photos or or
the opposite do you think you look
better like you always look bad in
photos I don't know yeah I think I look
bad in photos I answered yes to that one
everybody thinks they look bad and
different degrees
oh I think um I think it's yes
because we both get that comment when
people say hi to us on the streets this
one might be real
it's weird it's a weird question that's
not really for you to answer
that's to go with this I I think just
say yes
I'll take a green flag why not right
they take rack one up they take candid
pictures of you
oh wow this is crazy the women love it
50 I mean I don't take candid pictures
I'm not a big photo taker you don't do
it you're gonna take that one I I take
photos of you all the time
we got dipped so Ela gets a green flag
on that Ethan doesn't she's pulling
ahead my dude well it's true I mean she
definitely has more green flag than me
there's no question they identify as
liberal yes
okay so that's one for Ethan okay yes
friela
they are not on social media that's him
that to me would be kind of like
potential green flag
the women really love that about their
men
no it's the other way around
oh the oh I see which tracks from it
does track that's the fresh and fit
mentality right all right 44 of men like
if they don't have social media it's
interesting
so is the question if we are on social
media well we are yeah you both are so
that's that's not a green flag now we
should say we're obviously getting lower
and lower in the percentages here we
ended up doing the cutoff all the way
down at 10 which obviously is pretty low
but we just thought it'd be more
interesting if there was more to draw
from
they say there are only two genders
that's my I live by that that's my
personal ethos it's the one thing I
carry the most in life about
every morning that's a green flag
wait so more of a red flag yeah wait
yeah
again these charts are flipped so no
hold on hold on Norm they say there are
only two genders so men
men like when women say that
wow men are so pathetic good on a whole
they really just are so sad
oh we got some Taco Bell exciting look
how much sauce they put like excuse me
what am I a what
oh it's like one dip worth yeah oh we
have two different dips
oh this one might be the one I like more
look at those rectangles
it goes dude look at those rectangles
dude
rectangular
they own a gun
wow you sound pretty wild I own a I do
own a gun
that's a green flag for some people
uh men love it
we want our women armed
ELO you do not own a gun suppose you
guys co-own a gun
would you have got the gun if without me
no so I'll take the green flag
there you go
you needed to catch up anyway so
right
they say all lives matter I don't want
that flag
keep that flag
they send green text what kind of judgey
dumb is that that's a good question
that's the one thing I hate the most
about that's so stupid to me now I'm on
Apple
and I see they really with your
brain with these green attacks
I hate it I hate that they do that it's
so effed up
I hate it too but I mean we're about
using an iPhone right now so I guess
well because I had a thought like
you know I hate how Apple puts out a new
phone every year and then with
your phone like why should I support
them and I was like maybe I should get a
Android but then I'm gonna be a green
text weirdo
but don't they all do that
no
Apple's the only one that's like been
sued and lost for
land obsolescence
that's true
but it really is a mark of Shame the
green text
weird
um I've heard that I've heard that
you're a green text weirdo of course use
a iPhone hey my brother does
anyone tell that there's his diet
foreign
can't help you on that one this one
tastes real but honestly I can't tell so
hard to tell
[Music]
they have too many hobbies
too many how is that a green flag with
the way it's Frank it's like worded like
this is a problem
talk about Paul so I mean no I don't
have too many
obvious
they talk about politics frequently oh
yeah yeah
I don't know if I had to qualify for
that no you don't
they prefer cow milk over non-dairy milk
the men
we talk about politics all the time on
this show
on the show but in real life no
okay
do they taste I didn't
I wouldn't be surprised if they just
didn't care they just they're both real
yeah
I can't I'm not gonna drink a hole
I can take one of them
I'm not gonna drink any of them because
I don't want to drink a bunch of sugar
so if anyone wants to go for it I'd love
to
foreign
this is the Min preferences are just
funny 42 prefer women that drink cow
milk
why do you care
men like 35 when women
identify as conservative are into
astrology
pretty glad to see that low identify as
a communist
refuse to see the Barbie movie
these are pretty funny yeah these are
crazy
identify as Maga Republican
only seven percent of women are liking
that
they don't care about politics
listen to Joe Rogan dude seven percent
of women are saying
only seven percent like that
they watch reality dating shows nobody
likes that but that's everybody
likes that everyone's just too
embarrassed to admit it
green flag what
this is getting low yeah I'm just
curious now
they frequently posted social media they
don't like it they are so unbothered
they never ask for details
they have no Hobbies that's a flag for
some people
I Maya where'd it go
did you guys try the jalapeno sauce
it's really good there's like none in
the dark one
do you see how little they gave us it's
so little it's already out it's like
yeah I know what the hell the those
Taco Bell is supposed to be
I need this on top or like yeah it's but
it's supposed to be like a celebration
of uh
[Music]
what's the word
food perhaps I'm looking it up because
it's annoying me I can't remember it
uh
God damn it
it air
I'm just gonna move these are really
good by the way then the new item it's
real crunchy the fry job is good it's a
good fry job a fry job it's a good
Taquito frankly yeah they're crispy
all right back to the oracle
wish this apple decided to close for no
reason
yeah
um
all right let's go to the Reds this
one's gonna be fun
they identify as Maga this I love to see
man
and God bless the women once again even
I mean 60 of men too that is uh that's
frankly surprising majority yeah
it is a problem I mean if you are like
straight up Maga there's a good shot
you're just anti-social yeah if you're
like wearing the hat and everything oh
yeah that's definitely like you have a
personality it's bad news bad news
they have no Hobbies
would either of you say that you have no
Hobbies I'm afraid I don't think I have
hobbies
video games
but I don't think that video games I
don't yeah I think you do because but
also like
for people like us you kind of turned
your hobby into your business so it's a
little hard to say that you don't have
hobbies you do what you love sure that's
true you make music groups all the time
too yeah you make music but not like
yeah that would be a hobby that's a
hobby video games it's like is watching
movies a hobby like no right so like
video games but I think of that as like
I'm gonna this weekend I'm gonna go in
the garden and do you know what I mean
like it's a regular thing the gardening
would be a hobby I don't think I have a
hobby I I really don't all right well
that's a red flag for Ethan what do you
have a hobby drawing
I
haven't done it in a long time
raising kids is that a hobby yeah
I don't think I have a hobby
they say all lives matter
dude that's awesome
60 of women say that's just straight up
a red flag nope that's a nope
I don't say that for the record
there are only two genders no
I don't quite understand this they're so
unbothered they never ask for details
so it'd be like uh
like your uh say your girl when you're
dating a guy and you're gonna go out to
a club with a bunch of your girlfriends
uh and you and you say you say that and
the guys okay cool whatever oh
interesting I read it as like they don't
really want to know about your day I
mean why is the red flag I think it
means you're with somebody who doesn't
care about you it is the red flag I I I
that's not me
that's not my flag to bear
yeah I think it means this person
doesn't care about you yeah she's being
rude I loved it one of the top ones is
communist like there's like there's just
Communists walking around everywhere not
like
what is this the Red Scare
uh what year is it no I'm not a
communist
I don't think there's anything wrong
with being a communist
I wouldn't get I wouldn't say it's a red
flag to be a communist well
well
55 of people disagree with you or 55 of
women
fake Call Me ass grifter dog
had a crush on many Joe
Rogan 55 that's so awesome
obviously no
they identify as conservative that's
awesome no
they refused to see the Barbie movie
I did not see it but not because I
refuse so no
that's where I'm at I haven't seen it
but I'd like to see it
they don't care about politics I don't I
wouldn't say that about myself I care
about politics
they own a gun that's a red flag I guess
that would be a red flag
you got points on both sides for that
one
Mila doesn't own a gummy said yeah I
didn't give her one for that they
watched reality dating shows that's a
that's my flag to own for sure both of
you got that one
big time
talk about politics no regularly
into astrology I love that the men are
like hell no to that
41 of men said that's a red flag
um identified as liberal
that's my red flag I guess
it's getting a little silly it's just
like the inverse of the other ones right
exactly yeah I mean it is all silly but
but yeah we're pretty much there so
so let's see
so uh yeah the crew Stacks up yeah just
to recap that ELO was at five green
flags and three Reds so on balance she's
she's at a plus two Advantage here on
the dateability scale very good and
Ethan you're our dead even four and four
so you're just kind of not even there
you're just neutral who knows he could
be he could go either way
all right let's see who lied on their on
their results
Zach is a green flag
Champion it's about the same ratio as uh
elas three greens not too many Reds you
know leaning green not bad not bad
wow cam Cam's at a fat seven seven and
four right you have a lot of flags in
general that's 11 Flags
yeah this is what I found more
interesting is uh certain people have
significantly more on both sides than
others I think some of us were more
to be like
okay sure okay sure that's where I was
at that's where I was at too because now
that I'm seeing the numbers I'm getting
a little nervous
um Sam right there right there with me
we don't care on balance we don't we
don't care we don't care and it shows
Dan of course lied on his thing he's ate
Green Flash I did not lie
also lots of flags
but hey greens he's a good man they're
worth all the LIE
uh Allison's a very lucky uh woman
thanks a lot of green flags
some red though you know a b stop it
right now
Amy stop this I
swearing Flags one red the red flag
ahead
what were your seven green flags maybe
this result in itself is a red flag
right
wait wait what were your results the
green flags do you have it
[Laughter]
I mean Cam and I had had that many green
as well
it's really it's just that he has so I
want to know what are the green flags
okay
um
I read
you read green
okay
um how often do you read what was the
last book usually when Lena sleeps you
read it every night I have a book by my
bed I try to read every night and how
long have you been doing that uh about
three days
oh it just started
I used to a long time ago and I have in
a while I'm reading Malcolm X's
autobiography all right so he reads he's
a prolific uh reader yeah I mean that
that counts but actually actually she
reads a book when I was younger I was
the top Accelerated Reader in Dearborn I
don't know what that says I believe that
I peaked that in like fourth grade
you're a reader you're a reader
uh I believe black lives matter good for
you okay
uh I think I look better in person I
don't like mean photos
good for you you look good all the time
but good for you I identify as liberal
good for you
uh I own a uh I own a gun
that's agree Anna red that is a green
and a red yeah it doesn't make much
sense hey that's the nature of this
being inverted like that
[Music]
what else you got you stuffed the ballot
I watch reality dating shows there it is
okay
wait I thought that was over I mean it
is it's both I don't think was that a
green one
uh let's see on the green
green one doesn't count oh yeah that
does not count yeah it does not count
yes below the threshold
I researched deals before buying because
I definitely believe yes man you even
hear me listen about resources huge
green moment for the a b there I mean
that was high up there that seems
important that was the number two for
both men and women that was so weird to
me that it's number two yeah maybe does
give former gifted kids I would never
think about that what is that my dad I
need the best deal
or I'm gonna freak the it sounds
like whoa chill what Are You Gonna Save
like 20 bucks it's not that it's serious
do you care so much about this idea that
it made it to this list is what's weird
to me I think I don't think about in
terms of like saving money it's more of
like what I'm getting with that money if
you guys may have noticed the the
camera's a lot more stable today I've
been looking at stabilization all week
this is my new camera because of the
stabilization dealing with those shaky
hands they have pretty cool like
Parkinson's products you might want to
look into and I don't mean they have
like they have crazy ones where it like
auto corrects like have you seen the
Parkinson's film no
it is cool I know what you mean yeah
Ian just got a camera too and he has
shaky hands as well we've been
discussing disabled the shaky boys the
shaky boys together you guys get some
good stabilization there for y'all
okay yeah
yeah all right well you shot that uh
Zach thing that we did on Wednesday and
it looked great
well my green green friend you're so
green I might call you a rectangle
all right oh no
Lena's right there
she leans green which is a good score I
feel like this is a this is a green flag
score
right right
oh a good okay that's a lot of flat you
might have the most flags she has the
most flags I was pretty liberal with the
flags I'll say that 16 Flags my goodness
love with zero red one green
how do is that possible
that was not very liberal what was your
one green
um I don't remember
um what's it one of the questions like
do you hate black people no Okay so
yes or no yeah you know it was the black
lives matter one was for one green right
so right right they say black matter
like I've never really that's not really
in Sweden not what I'm saying
about American political record now so I
can gain an extra
black lives matter you said it he said
it so now he gets two now I have an F2
well what was the other other one wait
are you a liberal
I see that again that's not a
classification in Sweden so I haven't I
mean I guess most swedes would probably
consider themselves yeah but liberal
yeah so what was the one probably was
that I researched deals
he's the man this guy is gonna get good
that's the deal no red flash though I
don't I don't no red flags on this list
but um like um yeah I don't think so I
don't I don't know I don't know hold on
let me hold on I got I have some
follow-up questions for you okay
you have one green flag all right let's
see here this is gonna be interesting
I'm gonna hold your feet to the fire a
little bit here I was very little I
didn't think of this as as you guys did
because I thought are there only two
genders
um no
that would have been a red yeah that
would have been a red flag right yeah
so you so you believe there's there's
more than two genders that's a mad red
flag bro oh no I think you're saying the
opposite way nice
that's a green flag no that's a green
flag
say there are only two genders there's a
green flag yeah but that's a that you
don't want that
[Music]
it's so confusing trust me you don't
want that one just believe me on that
hold on hold on that's not a good green
flag to get
they say there are only two genders
there's a red flag in these people yeah
but he doesn't say it and love says
there's many okay so it's not a flag
um
let's see here
they don't okay I'm really trying to
catch them out I am I am I don't I don't
buy it
frequently post on social media oh what
about you gotta take that one I'm
personal I don't I probably post the
least hold on yeah tell me about your
job you got your job that way bro you
had a fan Twitter account
that's a red flag Less on social media
than most people take the Reds no I do
I don't know I think I posted the least
on the on the crew you say black lives
matter so that's something that's less
than me I like rarely post my last
Instagram post was months ago dude come
on you've been the most not on social
media you can't make even make the
argument okay come on come you say black
lives matter that's a red flag is it not
under 10. according to this
okay
you are not on well so this is below ten
so let me go over the green
you say black lives matter that's a fat
green one for you
I've said that now
[Applause]
do you prefer cow milk over non-dairy
milk nah you don't I don't have a
preference no he doesn't I thought you
don't laugh Dairy specifically I'm also
severely lactose intolerant and you're a
communist right
he's Swedish so yeah but that's a big
fat red flag
I guess uh I caught you on a few but not
that yeah the social media one I mean in
Context of everyone I do think I post
quite a lot less I think we all
approached it a little differently yeah
um well that's fine Ian coming in fat
fat Korean flags all over the place six
greens Two Reds what a guy
congratulations Sam
quite a partner you've been there in him
well there it is green flag red flag
[Applause]
there should be I feel like the
questions could be better like
do you do the dishes before being asked
you know what I mean sure you think do
you wash the laundry or do you let it
overfill that's a good question
do you spend have you spent eight hours
in a day playing video games in the past
four weeks I feel like I could write a
good one here okay do you have your
passports do you have your passports and
your shots and your shots yeah are you
asking a logical question right now
how about this do you do you road rage
do you vote in elections
we should make our own red flag green
flag hmm
like what the overlap was between us all
everything if we didn't talk about it
beforehand and then just see what we put
down
dude we should do that
you know
do you
um
do you talk with your family
I know that's not fair to some people
but it is interesting right do you talk
with your family yeah are you in contact
with your family that's I think that's a
very good one yeah
and again as a red or green that would
be well it could both it's it's these
are both I think right right you're
thinking of yeah more questions for this
survey you know are you close with your
mom
and again not your fault
but if we're just going out into the
world
right maybe your mom's a giant
dude somebody suggested do you
unpack in hotel rooms that's a good one
that is a really good question
um
do you wake up before 10 a.m or do you
you know what I mean like on the weekend
what do you wake up before 9 A.M
chat had a really good one how do you
treat waiters there it is right yeah I
don't think anyone would be awesome do
you have lice
do you have Lupus do you have some sort
of venereal disease are you rectangular
do you brush
do you shower
is rectangular red or green it's green
clearly it's green
do you uh
do you exercise regularly
you even lift bro yeah do you I mean
listen by this metrics I'm like these
are basically all my red flags I'm
listing right you're kind of screwing
you're giving my I'm putting myself out
there yeah do you do crack have you
smoked crap yeah have you ever smoked
crack once do you eat the vegetables it
sucks with you smoke crack with me are
you usually late
that's actually a really good one yeah
are you late to every day to work that's
fair
well at a certain point is it late or is
it right on time
you know what I mean
all right I don't like this game anymore
let's move off here
we don't much time so let's pick uh the
UFO Mexican Congress story is pretty
great
uh we never talked about you we didn't
talk about the aliens that's true and we
didn't talk about this milk thing right
the whole thing's pretty good it is yeah
it is let's do the now it's very good oh
this one guy I gotta put on blast hold
on
okay Tim gerner property developer and
multi-millionaire Tim gerner has
expressed The View that employees have
grown too arrogant and believe that a
substantial increase in unemployment
especially in the construction sector is
necessary to boost productivity listen
to this cycle
dude this guy's gonna get this guy's
gonna get me killed
he does not Eric can you do me a
favorian put up that this dumbass's
views do not reflect mine not for
YouTube but just for the
for the audience the Communists watching
the radical Communists watching are you
guys are not cold yeah it's a little
cold turn off the air I mean the the the
audacity to go out and say something at
the uh in public like like this is some
insightful thing I mean this man is a
demon
listen to this
gerner group so change the name psycho
girner group
I think the problem that we've had is
that we've you know we we have
people decided they didn't really want
to work so much anymore through covert
and that has had a massive issue on
productivity
definitely pull back on productivity you
know they they have been paid at paid a
lot to do not too much in the last few
years and we need to see that change we
need to see unemployment rise
unemployment has to jump 40 50 in my
view we need to see pain in the economy
we need to remind people that they work
for the employer not the other way
around I mean there is a there's been a
systematic change where employees feel
the employer is extremely lucky to have
them as opposed to the other way around
so it's a dynamic that has to change
we've got to ensure that attitude and
that has to come through hurting the
economy which is what the whole Global
you know the world is trying to do the
governments around the world are trying
to increase unemployment to get that to
some sort of normality and we're seeing
it I think every employer now is seeing
it I mean there is definitely massive
layoffs going off for people might not
be talking about it but people are
definitely laying people off and
starting to see less arrogance in the
employment market and that has to
continue because that will Cascade
across the cost balance can you imagine
actually like going out and seeing this
I mean what no you know what I just saw
what off this guy
is the guy that started the whole
avocado toast things dude hold on which
is what is that
huh how do you claim that that's like
claiming burrito no no no no no I'm
sorry he didn't say that he invented
avocado toast you remember there was a
controversy the whole meme of like well
Millennials should stop him yeah he
started that whole stop with all the
avocado toast okay you really hate poor
people yeah there he is oh wow full
screen that's crazy we are coming into a
new reality where first time buyers
second nine bars and a lot of people
won't own a house in their lifetime that
is just the reality of where we're going
so you think that young people have now
got the prospect of never owning a home
absolutely when you're spending 40 a day
on smashed avocado and coffees are not
working oh yeah of course oh that was it
I guess yeah spending all your money on
smashed avocado the die on smashed
avocado and coffees are not working of
course
it really sucks I'm also seeing that he
is one of these weirdos that uh wants to
be immortal
oh God that's another dude I haven't
talked about the immortal yeah I'm
obsessed with them this guy's seeing he
gets uh receives magnesium infusion his
well-being established bro you literally
look like you're doing a demonic ritual
what are you doing look at that with all
the candles
I hate you I actually hate you
he I mean he's I
I can say from our experience that he's
completely wrong
it's not the case about like
productivity going down because of covet
and people not wanting to work and all
the stuff that is wrong people just
don't want it if your business model is
reliant on exploiting workers then it is
going to affect their bottom yeah if
you're McDonald's if you're Walmart if
you're you know I mean in in a way we've
learned that a business can be more
accommodating to people and still work
like today some people might come for an
interview and they'll ask for a
uh I forget what's the word but like a a
position where they can work twice a
hybrid yeah twice at a week in the
office and then work from home the rest
of the week
stuff like that where I think it was
educational for everybody on both sides
and what are you trying to say Dan his
forehead is yeah dude it's like crazy
it's a good hairline and like that if
you follow like where his head actually
like the head is massive a lot of real
estate uh-huh that's his business I
guess maybe we should listen he's
probably pretty smart with that that
five head that's so sick
but like I I fundamentally disagree with
his theory that we must exploit workers
for it's like
dude when workers
like if I make more money and are are
better off and have health care and have
access to uh shelter affordable shelter
and food guess what Society is more
stable and going to have more longevity
for everybody when your philosophy is
let's exploit every single worker to the
max it's only a matter of time before
your head ends on a pike brother and it
is coming someday if you keep doing this
you will die
you know what can I just say something
else all these rich people who are
trying to live forever are the worst
they're the last people we want living
forever it's true you know what I mean
that's true sorry go ahead but it's just
like if anything I think it's it become
it became better for everybody like
employees know better they know what
they want and what works for them and
what to ask for now and employers can
accommodate that and and then the
employee can feel appreciated and feel
like they care about the job and
actually do a better job because they
still have free time to do what they
need they can go do a pers their
personal errands like it's just it's a
more
I don't know it's a better approach for
everybody actually what happens in
almost all office jobs where people have
to go to a specific place to work
there's no reason for them to be in that
location
50 or even more of the time lick
literally is just a quality of life
increase for them
that costs nothing and apparently to
people like this the workers suffering
is part of what he expects to get from
the salary he pays them
you know he feeds off of it what a piece
of dude I hate this guy how you
even gonna say that mm-hmm
um
you know I've been
I'm I know that I'm a capitalist
and so I've been trying to think like
how do you square that
with my other like socialist ideas
and I think there there is I think that
there if there isn't there should be a
thing and it's a little bit of an
oxymoron sounds silly but I do think
it's a real it can be and is a real
thing
benevolent capitalism
Scott no it's called being a Social
Democrat so okay so what what I think is
like
if you like the idea of capitalism
then you need to also accept the
inevitable
downsides of capitalism like
if how you live is dependent on you
working
right then you then you need to
guarantee people jobs
it doesn't make sense so because without
that then you're basically saying yeah
just as a consequence of this some
people are going to be homeless and
destitute
and so
that's unacceptable right I mean that's
psychoed I just accept that as a fact of
life
and so like I think the government
should have guaranteed jobs for people
that want to work
you know that pay enough to for the
minimum amount needed to have shelter
and food I think shelter should be
guaranteed I think food should be
guaranteed because again we want the
capitalist society and all the good
things that that that that benefits us I
do like the system of capitalism I think
it's good
but so we want all the good things but
at the same time it does if if it's
unchecked it makes Society uh the the
distribution of wealth and like the
stability of society goes totally off
keel
and if you need a job to provide
food and shelter then again that's the
capitalism right so you have to
guarantee those things so I think job
work food and shelter should be
guaranteed rights of people living in
capitalism and education
right and health health care should be
to you yeah I mean those are even like
the three most basic but I actually yeah
Healthcare you know should be and
education should be too you're right
because like and it makes sense to me
because you want to exist in this world
where it's all about money it's all
about Market forces and all this
so you can't just regulate on the top
you have to regulate on the bottom too
to control for the outcome
I just yeah so yeah you are everything
you just described is almost Social
Democrat to a t i mean this is what uh
this is what I think like um like FDR
Democrat I love his bill of his second
Bill of Rights yeah Democrats uh uh pre
like 1970s is everything that you're
describing this is ideologically
live up to all those things but that was
that was the kind of prevailing wisdom
at the time
the second Bill of Rights would have
been the greatest thing that happened to
this country man that's crazy
uh Ethan describe one good thing about
capitalism
I first of all I think it's like
the natural inclination of some people
like I don't think it's even realistic
to say
I want to live in like a perfect
communistic Society because that never
that just doesn't work there's
it's antithetical to human nature but I
do think there are good things of um
capitalism provides which is I do think
there's a sense of innovation that
happens when people are motivated by
money and pushed to you know do certain
ideas and and to invest in certain ideas
that like the government isn't doing
um
I
yeah
I also I don't hate the idea of like
people who can be successful I think
it's I think it's good that people can
can do can achieve success in the term
monetary success I mean that's what that
means right I do you know there's
nothing wrong with that it's it's
it's uh
it's good
I think it's I think it's good
you know
uh
yeah it right it encourages efficient
efficient production right I mean there
if there's a money incentive like if
everything was owned by the government
it would remove a lot of
efficiency perhaps when people aren't
motivated by money and stuff but this is
all this is all silly again
it all sounds very vapid and you know
uh when you describe it because
capitalism is inherently it seems like
based on Hedonism right it doesn't come
from like an altruistic place so that's
why the important part is to make sure
that there is altruism and Humanity that
is kept in this you know Rat Race which
is capitalism
that's it the second Bill of Rights FDR
tried to pass and he was close to man
the right of every family to a decent
home the right to adequate Medical Care
and the opportunity to achieve and enjoy
good health the right to adequate
protection from economic fears of old
age sickness accident and unemployment
the right to a good education he was
going to draft the second Bill of Rights
and it was close it was really close to
passing
he was on some Keen wouldn't you
know
there you go I don't know what the
you want from me
I just I think that capitalism is a more
realistic system of governance than like
uh communism is you know
I mean it never works because people are
inherently corrupt and whoever's in
charge is gonna
they're gonna be greedy they're gonna be
corrupt they're gonna everything up
it doesn't make sense to me that that
system could work
where everybody just acts in good faith
and does the right thing
so as long as there's no like Mega
losers in capitalism if that's something
we can
regulate then I do believe that it can
be a
a benevolent thing yeah capitalism
Breeze greed exactly and you know they
say greed is good and there is some
truth to that in measure right it's you
know it is it's an inherent
quality of man and it can sometimes
Drive uh Innovation efficiency all those
kinds of stuff you know
you think that because you benefit from
it Ethan
obviously
yeah yes
well his opinion is obviously going to
be
his opinion based on his experience but
that I feel like that's always been my
opinion frankly
so I'm just saying the fact that it
benefits you is obvious that it's gonna
affect your opinion it is your opinion
it just seems like this like uh
Socialist Communist uh
uh idea that people want is like just a
pipe dream what is the idea that people
want
I'm kind of curious because I see so
many people in the chat saying no I
don't know what y'all are tripping about
like what the do you what is the
idea that you guys are looking for I
don't know to hear I actually don't know
like it's almost like weird virtue
signaling to be like I'm living in
modern day America but I want a full
Communist Revolution
I don't know what the
I'll take on Humanity dude you guys are
Dan do you know because you know
everything yeah I don't really
doing you really want to get into this
right now I don't mind
I'm actually curious what because like
it seems like majority of the chat is
disagreeing and so we have a very
left-leaning uh uh audience here on the
H3 podcast and um and I'm sure plenty of
people agree with you I'm sure but um
and obviously I think we are
left-leaning too anti-capitalists are
going to speak up when you're uh giving
an impassioned defense of it but um I
would say it's impassionate but
I am a capitalist what do you want you
know what I mean yeah I think it's but
the thing is like they think that like
workers should share in the uh
the uh
yeah that's the fundamental difference
is that workers should get a percent of
your earnings
essentially the a percentage of their
production
you know I I
don't really I don't I don't agree with
that
I don't think I mean in some cases it's
true but I think employ you do have an A
obligation to make sure your employees
are well provided for you know what I
mean like that's for sure
suck it chat
you're watching you're watching a
capitalist fig deal with it
I don't know what the you guys are
all like radical Communists there's that
many radical Communists they're not
radical Communists not everybody that's
anti-capitalist is a communist it is
kind of a radical take that being at
like full anti-capitalist that means
you're you're essentially advocating to
change the entire structure of all
societies today on Earth that's not
radical
is there anywhere in the world that is
doing that
not really China's apparently communist
but it's not it's not and the people
couldn't do whatever they wanted
uh well not really yeah that's not
really yeah Russia is well what I don't
know what Russia is no not really I
don't think there is
oh my God I don't think there really is
but how is being anti-capitalist not
radical
just in theory because like because the
United States isn't the whole world dude
like what country is not I mean I
believe I'm from Israel but it's pretty
much the same thing anti-capitalist
socialist political parties some of them
in power at times some of them it's
definitely they're capitalist countries
bro
name one European country that isn't a
capitalist country no yeah you're right
all they're all capitalist countries
okay
you know there's plenty to criticize for
modern capitalism
Lots it's not working in its current
form it's just totally broken in its
current form like this late stage
capitalism that uh like this Reddit like
it's very poignant I believe uh with the
late stage capitalism you know it's not
working for sure
but like name one you know social
democracies do great in Europe yeah
Sweden for example yeah I'm because
you're explaining Sweden pretty much
right yeah exactly like a capitalistic
country with insanely high social
benefits
that's what I've lived in my whole life
and I'm curious what these people
have to criticize I mean there's a lot
of I understand you have a radical
communist right next to you I actually
don't know what the criticism is for
Sweden's economy
um so that's exactly what I would love
to see like that's what I don't
understand why everybody is like that
and I'm sure there are I'm not saying
there isn't I'm genuinely curious I
don't know
I think that I spent a lot of young
people see that capitalism whether you
think it has brought a lot of
improvements to people's lives
um is
A system that is
killing the planet and um
and especially in the last 30 to 40
years most people I think in at least in
I can really only expect I'm just going
to speak on the United States because
that's my experience and what I've done
around
um is like you said uh you're just
talking about that subreddit that's kind
of all centered around it uh I I feel
like people see the decline happening
and they're fundamentally unhappy with
the way that we have arranged our
society and to act like it was eternal
and was always like this is is kind of
naive I mean it capitalism
well because capitalism is something
that has only existed for about 200
years and like the form that we know it
I didn't say it's always been like this
right but I'm not saying that like you
think that we have figured it out that
we've found the best system of
organizing Society I think I think that
you know we're at the end of History I
think part of it you have to uh tangle
with is what's realistic like what's a
realistic okay
I feel like if we're talking about him
what is realistic about a society that I
mean we live in Los Angeles there's
thousands of homeless people starving on
the street in our neighborhood I'm not
advocating for that right but I'm saying
that people see the flaws in the system
that we currently have and so that they
I see them too and there's a lot of this
is the thing you you're saying like
everybody's a radical communist that's
not necessarily the case being
anti-capitalist doesn't equate that it
just is somebody that has landed on the
side of the coin that they think that
the system that we have that capitalism
is not working and there's a I agree
variety of people away from that well
and some people I mean most
Republicans and I would say even a lot
of Democrats would say what you just
described that Social Democrat kind of
point of view they're not would say that
you are anti-capitalist with that point
of view because that's fine then I
accept that right and say whatever the
is social Democrats are very often
seen as kind of like
right on the fence between the the what
people call the left and the right so
I'm watching in the middle contact like
the Buddha himself
right you're taking the middle don't you
feel though that here in America like
people can't even afford health care or
education so like isn't a social
democracy
a first step that we should all try to
get to yeah a lot of people before like
trying to get to like the amount of
nuance and degrees here yeah so I think
that this I think that it's like for us
we're mostly talking about like what we
see is realistic like what's the first
step that we should at least try to get
like the bare minimum I am still I'm
I've been here seven years I'm still
shocked about Healthcare like it it
shocks you every single time I deal with
it it is shocking I paid 200 just to get
a blood test like it's insane it's
insane
so to me it's like yeah we we can talk
like philosophical and we can talk all
kinds of things but I feel like
what's actually going to happen what's
something that would be a first step to
improve
well I mean there's a variety of
opinions on that and you know a lot of
people would say that it does need to be
an incremental thing and we need to work
towards that
um I mean even even people who describe
themselves as Communists say that
because again like the USSR for example
which is the most famous example of like
a big country a big superpower level
country that people consider Communists
right within their own framework they
they never thought that they were
communist they thought they were taking
steps towards communism and in in a
variety of different ways and so it's
just about like that that's an ideal
that's like an end goal that people who
would self-describe as Communists are
now some what I would say a radical
communist is is somebody that wants a
violent revolution to overthrow the
government and take over and Implement
that system as closely as possible now
which is something that has happened in
a variety of places to varying degrees
of atrocities that fell out of it when
you say you're an anti-capitalist though
does that mean that you are critical of
capitalism
I think you just you say you're a
capitalist but it's a lot more because
Nuance I'm not against the idea of
capitalism I think it's a good system
with the correct with a lot of
Corrections because when you say you're
anti-capitalist it sounds like you're
saying and correct me if I'm wrong you
don't believe in capitalism as a
governing uh uh
what it comes down to me too is when you
when you throughout that line from uh
glendary Glenn Ross about greed being
good or whatever
I I don't think so that's like a isn't
that like a yeah that's like
um I don't think that's the first time
that was written
well go ahead anyway regardless it's
certainly not the first time that people
have felt that way but that line that
you that people often repeat is from
that play but um
anyways yeah I mean all it comes down to
me is that I just I don't think
arranging Society based on Greed is uh
good for the human spirit and I think we
see the consequences of that all around
us so a hyper capitalistic Society like
greed needs greed needs to have bumpers
okay because that the idea that we can
live in a society without greed is a
fairy tale it just doesn't exist and you
can't approach a practical way of
governing a huge body of people uh
without looking at it realistically
because at the end of the day if you
look at the USSR again and uh I mean
it's a it's a catastrophe because the
people on the top who rise to the top
are the ones that are pathological they
are greedy that happens in our society
it is but like but but but it that's not
the antithesis of everything you think
that capitalism does a better job at uh
you have to be aware say listen we live
in a world where greed is is um
inevitable and so we need to harness
that for the good that it does provide
and we need to put on bumpers for the
bad things it does do because if we're
like yo we need communism and uh let's
everybody needs greed is bad and nobody
you know everyone is equal you're
there's the Cycles are gonna rise to the
top
and they're and they're not gonna
do what needs to be done it's
just not gonna happen
um and it's not realistic people are
gonna cut they're gonna not gonna live
that way they're not gonna live that way
the Psychopaths which there's going to
be like 10 20 are just full-on
psychopaths are the ones that are going
to pick become powerful and they're just
they're going to take advantage of the
system they're going to become our
oligarchs they're going to become so do
you believe that is do you think the
United States with like its um with its
democracy
like our election system and democracy
gives good safeguards or at least gives
some safeguards to preventing the
sociopaths like you're talking about
that rise up through like a totalitarian
that's not that's not even a problem
that you can control for I I there's no
way we're gonna
becoming billionaires elections and
being a democratic and term limits or
having our president change every four
years oh are you talking about like rich
people or elected officials I'm talking
about elected officials I'm talking
about like essentially what I'm asking
is do you think democracy is a good
thing and do you think democracy is what
helps prevent yeah yeah but but
obviously our democracy isn't perfect
either right you know but you think
ultimately that
being a democracy living in a society
that votes and has you know the people
agree on how we should who should
represent us and who should lead us is
something like that's a better system
than like say China right where yeah
they have a council of Elites and
somebody yes elected from within right
yes okay so
what if we ran companies that way
because companies aren't democracies
they're totalitarian so how do you run a
company so first of all usually how come
how are companies made usually um are
you saying like like an entrepreneur
starts a small business like apple let's
just take Apple or Google right it's
made by a few entrepreneur uh you know
enterprising people so yada yada yada
it's made by three four people Apple uh
and over the years it's growing it's
growing
and so how do you run Apple at what
point does it become like subject to
public opinion on who's gonna run it
that's just like that at what point does
it get big enough to make good questions
decisions and that's something that
see that's that's why I have a question
about what happened about elected
because like independent artist is also
running a business and could be making a
lot of money depending there's a wide
range so um how do we like what do we
Define as businesses aren't government
no they're not they they're part of the
freedom we enjoy but but I agree that
like that company like Google is almost
like government yeah we're you know
that's a whole different aspect of
regulating these like monster yeah
businesses
right and oftentimes you know when when
there are
critical parts of society that we deem
like off limits to the private sector we
we're like let's say like the military
we don't you know the government has a
monopoly on that right on Monopoly on
like keeping an armed force and
everything yeah and at least in theory I
mean obviously there's a whole different
conversation but you know in the United
States we have some uh say over what our
military does as a result of that right
because we elect the people we elect the
commander-in-chief we elect who's in
charge and we elect the person who is
able to control the Armed Forces right I
mean theoretically the Armed Forces
should be controlled by Congress which
hasn't really ever oh sure you're right
yeah according to the Constitution so
but you're saying you're saying what are
you saying just you know what I mean I'm
just saying that there are we can agree
that there are certain things in society
that we have decided that it's best if
this is uh not left up to the
entrepreneurial Spirit right yes
government should be in charge of of
stuff that has great social right and so
some people might think that
weren't like the work that people are
required to do to live in our society
is also something essential and should
be controlled more democratically in the
same way that we control government
institutions how like what the I mean
how what do you mean how we do we there
are public institutions right but so
electricity isn't invented by one dude
who's just like I have this great idea
I'm gonna make a company
okay
the Internet isn't owned by one dude you
know what I mean water isn't owned by
one dude just by the dentist
how are you going to go to a guy who who
founded Google
and say how do we make the government
we're taking it for the government so
what does that mean what does that mean
okay well I mean so
I feel like there's two tracks here
because there's how do we Tran like
you're now asking like how because we're
in deep right we're there's a sunk cost
here we we've built a society the way
that we are and ripping that all out is
going to be a very disruptive process so
you're right like what you know
if if the government tomorrow were to
nationalize all of Silicon Valley and
just say yeah these are all publicly
owned and take it all away obviously
people wouldn't go quietly with that and
especially the people that owned Google
that they wouldn't like that right and
so I mean that that's something that has
happened in history a lot when socialist
revolutions happen when the you know the
revolution happens and it's like okay
we're going to nationalize all the oil
industry like that all just belongs to
the government now you don't get to own
that as a private as a private citizen
anymore and so
where is that line what is essential to
society what is it again oil you're
talking about a natural resource I'm
talking about like a you know a big
company sure they invented their own
product and sell it I personally don't
think there's anything wrong with with
you know
the rules that govern that come from you
know the people from the concepts of re
of guards guard rails high level you
know that they have to treat their
employees with a certain level of they
have to compensate them to a certain
yeah
and listen social I don't I don't have a
problem with what you're describing
really like I agree I mean and I don't
think putting the government in charge
is going to improve anything if you were
talking about like massive businesses
like you know Google again just to use
an apple you're talking about natural
resources that benefit all people that
need they need them then then that's it
then you know but listen I'm open to
having a debate of all these things I'm
not I'm not saying one way or the other
conversation about it I just think that
um
you know I think it comes down to again
where that line is drawn and it's like
like internet stuff for example you're
right I mean especially in the early
days when it's just little companies uh
figuring it out but then at a certain
point
when does the internet become a human
right when does the when does your acts
when does you know living in society
does the internet become a requirement
and does it become up to deny
people that because they can't afford it
sure no I agree with that and so it
starts to get kind of gray right well I
don't I'm listen I'm I'm looking at this
Nuance I'm not saying we need to have
conversations about stuff as it happens
and we need to have it from like a
benevolent point of view and a realistic
point of view I'm not saying
I'm open to having a conversation about
socializing anything right but that's
what it should be it should be a
conversation and about like the social
good that something can have and if it
needs to be right is it being you know
is this business being owned privately
uh to a great detriment to the majority
of people
are people not having access to it who
need it
um and this is a conversation
basis yeah and so you're an
incrementalist and you think and so far
like we're talking about the really big
companies which we all agree on that
like Google Facebook
oh the scary stuff I agree 100 but like
what about the in between what about
everything else like under that but I'm
not but again we're talking I'm talking
about like regulations I'm talking about
like Anti-Trust I'm not talking
about gut full government takeovers of
the company okay right but it doesn't
um the full government takeover of the
company is the extreme end of that but
like the middle ground of what I'm
talking about is Unions that's what
union I'm pro-union I think unions are
great and I think workers should have
power so right and so all a union really
is is in a sense it's somewhat
democratizing a workplace because now
the union gets a say in how the business
is conducted hey the workers were we're
all getting together and we're saying
unless you and prove this unless you do
this we're not showing up that we're
going to prevent a notification this is
a conversation you know what I mean it's
not like it's not a government
interjecting and telling a business what
they can and can't do I want to sense it
is because government gives protections
to unions we at one point decided that
these are important and we created a
structure I'm in favor of that right
because prior to that the owners of the
factory or whatever when the workers
tried to do something like that they
literally shoot them right so
yeah you know what I mean not okay that
that happened okay but I'm in favor of
of unions okay well and by the way if
you look at again what you look at
Scandinavia which I think is like as
close to a mod as a model
right right yeah right extremely and
probably tons of laws protecting unions
and so again I'm looking at social
democracy like in Scandinavia and saying
this is a model society and it's as
close as we're gonna get as an equitable
Society realistically too I'm trying to
understand what is the point we don't
agree on
well I just I don't care
you're saying
anti-capitalism are you opposed to the
idea of capitalism because I agree that
capitalism in its current form is on as
unsustainable I would say that I am
opposed to it but I would say I am far
less radical than many that think that
we should tear it down immediately I
think that the the ripple effect of that
would inevitably be extremely violent
and disruptive to society and I I'm I'm
more of the incrementalist now I I would
say I am for the left of you because I
think that the end goal should be a
little bit further in that direction
than what you're saying but and what
which is
what way yeah like what in what way are
you first of all the saying like
capitalism shouldn't exist is like
I feel a fairy tale it's just not a
realistic expectation for for humans to
I I just like for me it's like Define
what would that look like I just want to
like get to an understanding where we
understand really simple terms I think
that
you know a a an incrementally push left
Society that's moving away from
capitalism a little bit would likely
have
um have companies use profit sharing
models with their employees on a much
bigger basis and you see some companies
doing that but the if you look at if you
study it over time what has happened is
the opposite of that is that the profits
of companies are getting concentrated
more and more up well we're just talking
about regulating and stuff again right
so I I would say that
one thing that you could do is you could
regulate it that you as a c as an owner
and a CEO of a company the profits that
the company is generating you're
obligated to share that with the people
that work for you on a much bigger scale
it's just a matter rather than how right
now which the goal always is to pay your
workers as little as possible that that
is and that's not like that's human
nature bro that's why we need to adjust
where that bar is we need to agree that
that bar because listen it's only
natural that's why I'm saying that far
away we're talking in degrees of how far
you move the bar I'll probably move it
further than you but I'm not I don't own
a company but yeah I mean listen if
you're just debating on like how much to
compensate your employees fairly that's
like uh
you know
and we're talking about first steps I
think every company should give x amount
of profits to employees
it's also
it's also overly complicated because in
the sense it's like what if you don't
have a profitable year then the
employees make less also fudge the
number how many businesses fudge your
number but that what you just described
happens all the time
what happens is not good what is
happening is not good we both agree
yeah yeah no I think yeah obviously we
both agree on that yeah 100 percent
what you said what's hap like what's
happening what's happening now is not
good yeah but so but okay I think
raising I think
bare minimum bar of of what we provide
uh rights to basic human rights to
people like FDR was carving out is a
better system personally and a simpler
system a more realistic system
okay I feel like I feel like the
conversations of like how far to go
are like
half them but I feel like
first I just want to see like normal
happening you know what I mean like
that's the thing is like that's that's
why again because that's almost like I
have like my personal beliefs of like
idealism of like what how I would love
to see the world work in like rainbows
and everything and then I have the other
side of like okay we live in the real
world what can happen or whatever and so
those are those are different
conversations and so yeah I mean for now
I would yeah the public health care
would be great you know like that's the
thing is in my opinion we're in such a
bad spot that like yeah you know we're
I'll I'll take uh just getting Medicare
for all like that that would be a huge W
sure and that's that's
in my opinion not far enough but I'll
take it I'm not going to say no to that
right
people think that
I don't know listen people people think
it's being pessimist to say it's human
nature to be greedy
show me one time in a big organized
Society where that wasn't the
inevitability of like deep-seated
societal destroying corruption but do
you want to live in a society that
encouraged that or do I want to live in
a perfect Utopia yeah yeah but no I'm
not saying perfect Utopia I'm saying we
quite a few people that run our country
and this and I'm not saying you feel
this way because this isn't your opinion
but this is the profailing attitude in
this country is that we it's a good
thing to arrange the way we run society
around let's Embrace that greed let's
let's use it for good like you said
rather than hey this is a fundamental
part of human nature we should check it
yeah
so that's the difference well it's to me
not that big of a difference I think
there's a fundamental difference I'm not
saying like
there are per people who are going to be
extremely Innovative and effective that
are going to be motivated by wanting to
be really rich and Powerful yeah I mean
I mean Elon Musk is a good example the
guy's a psycho piece of I
hate him on a on a level but like what
he's achieved
with Tesla is undeniable in terms of
moving Eevee
to mainstream it just is undeniable
right and I don't even want to give him
the credit because I hate him I
think he sucks
but like saying like promoting making
this you know distinction between
promoting greed
or putting guard rails to prevent from
greed it's just there's not a
significant difference there in my
opinion
unless you can unless you can explain
by the way people were saying this is
worse than dead air the show's over
right
I mean it's been over just leave if you
don't like what time is it it's past
five it's after five we got caught up we
gotta go you gave yourself no green flag
because for not wanting to talk about
politics and then you just launched into
an hour-long diet Rock about socialism
versus capitalism so liar
I think social democracy is the way to
go it's just realistic man and I'm
pro-union and I think people should be
fairly compensated I think people are
entitled to right own a home title too
people entitled to you know have healthy
meals
and I also think that
I don't think that we should regulate
how rich people can be if they're
existing in that
in that sandbox
like I'm not one I'm not gonna come out
here and say billionaires shouldn't
exist because if you can become a
billionaire in this sandbox where you're
paying your fair share to provide for
people in this way making sure you live
in a side of where people get houses
where people get food where people get
education if you can do all that and
still be a billionaire then there's no
problem with that in my opinion there's
just
well you know what I mean this
discussion before but I think it just
comes down to whether or not you believe
you can get to that level without doing
horrible
doing horrible you mean like can
you can you is that even an attainable
thing without being an immoral person
there's diff billionaire has become a
huge range you know look at people on
the top there were 200 300 billion yeah
Elon Musk billionaires that's yeah like
a lot more than a one million can you
become that rich without doing horrible
things definitely not can you get one
billion dollars without doing horrible
things probably well billionaires
shouldn't exist as a Snappy slogan like
maybe you can quibble about where the
line of acceptability is but I think you
understand in principle that at a
certain point that level of wealth
concentrated wealth and and my model
Society
I don't think people could become that
rich what about like Taylor's Taylor
Swift Ward's 740 million dollars just an
Entertainer yeah
she's well that's what I'm saying that
when you say billionaires shouldn't
exist I think it's about time we start
making a distinction between like 100
billionaires and like you know single
digit billionaires because there is a
big difference you know what I mean
there is you know like a lot of music
because again not really it's a
political slogan at the end of the day
and I feel like it gets the it gets the
world I think that it it's not
self-serving because I think plenty of
people see that and they think what I'm
seeing and they think that's that's
silly why shouldn't people be able to be
successful because there are people who
are way too rich and evil you
know clearly who got that rich it's you
know I I just I think there's a
difference between
um
like let's see Elon Musk is 300 how
wealthy is he like he's like 250 billion
or something like that there's 250 times
richer than a one billionaire
so let's say you have obviously he's on
the most extreme let's say you have ten
thousand dollars in the bank but what's
one that times 250. you know what I mean
like the difference is at is really
quite huge 250 times you know 2.5
million right so that's a big difference
right between ten thousand I'm not yeah
that's the difference between having ten
thousand dollars and 2.5 million yeah
but having a billion dollars is like
is like you can do anything you want
having 200 billion dollars is like you
can influence elections and change and
you can like fundamentally control the
outcome of current events yeah well I
mean listen again it sounds like I
pretty much agree with you in principle
it's just we disagree about where the
line is I think if you're at a billion
you're already well over the line to you
maybe it's more than that but if it's a
musician that got there I don't think
they did anything bad you know you're
saying you're saying you you had to have
done there's bad stuff to get to a
billion dollars Taylor Swift is almost a
business is almost there if not already
there because I'm just looking at Google
you know I don't know how accurate is
listen rock stars are cool and they can
be as rich as they want
okay
let's see Beyonce I don't know Brianna
well I mean Jay Z Rihanna is accordingly
1.4 billion it should be good she makes
a lot of money from from being from
business okay but I don't think she
necessarily does bad stuff to get there
I don't I don't well she I don't know
who's the person but that's the thing is
that's the thing is once it gets to a
certain point there's something along
the line that if you probably involving
some like child slavery or something you
know what I mean even even without their
knowledge but it's like the system lends
itself to that again because we're so
focused on incentivizing finding the
least common or the lowest common
denominator in everything
by which I mean seeking to maximize
profits seeking to minimize expenses
however you can and there's a lot of
people that are immoral and they don't
give a
um about if you know this is coming from
child slavery in some West African
country or whatever someone said Ethan a
billion dollars would change my life
it doesn't frown on that really and sure
a lot of ways I think that's another
philosophical conversation about like
how is our society whether it be
pure Socialism or democracy how is it
using and affecting you know other
countries you know that that's a that's
all I think perhaps a different
conversation that you can have and you
can have the same conversation
regardless but
you know
I I see a world where you can become a
billionaire ethically it's not
impossible you make there's 300 million
people living in America yes and there's
a ton there's a ton of money here if you
invent a really awesome thing
you can become a billionaire without
doing a single thing wrong
Maybe
I feel like that's a pretty that's the
middle path that's the real Budapest
become a billionaire but harm no other
in the process I think I think it's
possible I I really do I don't know what
to say that's the middle way but I'm not
I'm not saying you go out there and be a
billionaire I'm just saying I don't
think we need this self-imposed like
here's the line rich and no richer I
just don't think I don't think you
should let a slogan like that bother you
so much but I don't you agree with the
with the spirit of the slogan I don't
think the slogan serves itself well
because like I said people are not
seeing it like we're just talking about
like 100 billionaires people see that
and they say no the poor Bill single
billionaire how are you but like come on
they're not they don't like the idea of
you coming and taking people's money
it's just it's not a it doesn't make
sense like how are you gonna do that
I mean isn't that what taxation is
that's I mean that's all they're talking
about well they go 99 tax over every
dollar of a billion that's silly I mean
that's what FDR wanted
99. there was I think the top tax
bracket in that FDR wanted was maybe it
wasn't 99 but it was like 95 or
something let's see top tax bracket
uh let's see
75 75 is what they got I believe the he
want yeah 90 percent
well I think 90 is too high but 75
minutes but we're talking like yeah in
in modern dollars that was probably 90
of every dollar over like five ten
million that you made that year right
it's a it's a it's a tax break yeah it's
a progressive tax and I like the tax
bracket I think 75 is probably more
realistic you know well that's what it
was and now we're now we're at what like
by the way I don't think anyone gets
taxed that high in the whole world
what's one country that charges the
richest people over 75 it doesn't exist
oh
I don't think it I don't know off the
top of my head I I know that I mean
maybe but I'm cool with that what's the
top tax bracket in Sweden in those
Nordic countries it's pretty awesome
55. it's not like more than what I pay
here I pay about 55 okay dividends like
you can't like you can just pay yourself
dividend 20 well right and that's the
reality here too is that everybody uh
that's rich knows how to get around that
and just okay it's also important I know
to like defend the Democracy from
capitalism because here like lobbying is
crazy I feel like that's what's serving
America and that's my point is like I
feel I I well I didn't make this point
very well I was trying to make the point
earlier but this is why I was asking
about what you think about democracy in
general is that the capitalism is in
it's it's anti-democratic and and in
more than one sense and what Love's
talking about is like how the money can
corrupt our democracy and everything is
a part of that but just in general like
we we run
the expectation is that companies are
run
from the top down in a very hierarchical
hierarchical way and that there isn't
much say from from the bottom up you
know what I mean it's the inverse of how
we run our government and so you know
defending against the uh
the worst Tendencies of that I think is
important and that's what I advocate for
I'm always so confused because you want
to replace the system and I guess me and
Ethan want to
[Music]
talk
I I buttoned that well okay oh what
happened I didn't even hear me and I
felt like maybe it came off wrong I said
maybe that is his name
over there
what was it what's the actual name
I don't even know what you're going for
I have no idea
you were trying to call me a uh
communist yeah yeah what was his name
are you talking about Mao yeah
[Music]
so you're yeah
I don't know I'm trying to think I guess
I said uh
me and Ethan want to fix the system like
capitalism like put Band-Aids over where
it kind of leaks no not Band-Aids
because that sounds bad
we want scaffolding I mean I don't know
why I I don't you don't get why because
the system because instead of replacing
it well we're talking about I mean I am
talking about fixing the system as well
but the sure my way of fixing it would
be modifying it significantly more than
what you're saying
mandating it not to use that term but
yeah yeah so how do you prevent people
from being billionaires just by doing a
99 task I mean that's a real easy way
right I mean FDR thought it was and yeah
I mean well okay you want to talk about
democracy I mean FDR is not a he's not a
tyrant either you know what I mean he
got 75 ultimately like you said and I
think that's I would do 90 I think it's
fair anywhere between 75 and 90 for the
utmost you know 99 to me just it seems
it seems silly to me to tax someone 99
even if they're a billionaire well you
know when he said uh when he was going
for the 90 and got 75 that probably
wasn't negotiating tactics you know what
I mean okay so 75 I mean what the
that's not enough you know what I mean
let's go you know people can go I think
people are jaded on capitalism
understandably yeah I mean
obviously it's easy to see its flaws
because we exist in it now and I
understand from my perspective thanks to
Gary Vee's advice
that I am like a winner in capitalism
right you might say w thank you
different perspective and so listen I've
been on the losing end of capitalism too
and more and more it's screwing us over
but what I'm saying is we don't need to
throw the baby out with the bathwater
people oh yeah it's hard to it's hard to
feel uh you know charitable to a
capitalism as a concept whenever almost
everyone's being burned by it but
again at Scandinavia I think that's as
close as a model uh society as as we've
achieved in human history
I just I want Jimmy Lee to start paying
his employees that's all I care
I'll take it even further I think it
should be illegal to have unpaid
employees period
you know what I mean I think it is
um well no internships like the internal
relationship I mean yeah uh
that does seem
a little gray though doesn't it I'm
surprised by how many people think that
like
by the way I say radical communism
because again you're talking about
undoing the
vast uh
again there's like so many like ways
marriage I mean every country communist
ones are operating via capitalism
right well there's a lot of nuance to
that too I mean a lot the whole thing
with dig it out man
what's that you could just dig it out
and replace it anti-capitalism I don't
know I mean I'm well listen a lot of
people again a lot of people agree with
you that uh not in this game with uh
reform rather than Revolution
of what the superior strategy is
yeah
but I think yeah I think capitalism gets
a bad rep just because that you know up
until now it hasn't been checked and
we're at this point now where uh we call
it late stage capitalism where it really
is on life support and it's just not
working it's not a good system unchecked
capitalism is evil it's not working well
but I do think that a hybrid system of
socialism capitalism is a really good
system that can be humanistic benevolent
and serve the also the productivity and
Innovation that some people would say
capitalism
um breeds sure
thank you
all right we really got by the way I
want to say
some of you guys in chat are so annoying
like I'm not oh don't let them I'm not
advocating like y'all act like I'm
saying like uh I think that there should
be no minimum wage and people should be
like if they can't afford a
h
come on stop it
well people act like I'm stomping on
workers faces because I don't because I
don't rev show the audience has a wide
range of views uh and obviously leans
pretty far left just because you know
the all the personalities on this show
do listen every time a measure comes to
raise taxes in LA or otherwise I always
vote Yes I said I'm gonna pay 75 is that
not enough for you guys 75 who what
other rich person is saying that
find one well as I am not a radical
communist so you I I can't make that
argument for them I'm sure they will in
the comments section and on their edit
over the next few days but uh but yeah I
mean I think the greed is good thing
threw people off too I think that people
being greedy is an inherent and
inevitable trait of human uh
of the human Spirit I'm not saying of
everybody I'm not saying everybody's
greedy I'm saying if you take a thousand
people a certain percent of them are
going to be greedy and motivated by
power and wealth and Status okay and a
lot of times there's going to be an
oversect of these people's being
sociopaths and being super capable super
smart and
um
we can't harness that this
for what good it can do which is like
Innovation productivity efficiency and
stuff like that
wow also regulating it to make sure it
doesn't also ruin
society and that it serves uh
uh people well in general
and I and I think that's just realistic
it doesn't matter if you're in a society
so it doesn't matter if you're living in
pure socialism doesn't matter if you're
living in you know any form of
governance there's gonna be a percent of
people that are highly capable
intelligent sociopaths obsessed with
money and status and power
and so you know and there's going to be
good people that are successful too
that's not what I'm saying but these are
the people that really cause the problem
and so
let's not encourage them you're that's
just how you do not incur that's a human
nature bro like I just don't believe
that there's everything you just don't
think that there's anything that you can
do about people being greedy and
people over there's nothing people are
born with you know that's like
saying I don't want anyone to be born a
sociopath and sociopaths I'm not saying
I'm not saying you're not gonna you're
not gonna end nobody sociopathy yeah of
course not I'm not saying that of course
I agree with what you're saying that you
know that there's
people are greedy just should that
behavior be real I don't know what that
means what do you mean rewarded maybe
and now it is but I'm saying again
nobody Ian's telling you to shut up uh I
I have to pee I'm sorry I don't know
what do you mean what do you mean I
don't even know what that means it's
encouraged I mean it is what it is you
said it yourself you said greed is good
I just said that that was misconstructed
but here's the thing but okay fine I'm
saying it's inevitable right you don't
believe harness it for the good right
don't believe that
unfortunately a lot of the people that
run
the world do okay well that's inevitable
I see I don't think that that's a nipple
that's where we differ well regardless I
don't think it should matter what people
think because ultimately in the in the
way that the framework that things are
built it's not going to matter what they
think about greed I agree that's going
to be and that's that's why it's not a
great framework in my opinion
why because of what you just said it's a
framework that doesn't it doesn't matter
what you think about greed uh-huh right
and it controls the worst outcome for
what they can do how is that bad it
controls the worst outcome yeah and my
Social Democratic uh Utopia
oh oh you're saying and you okay yeah we
were talking about I'm talking about the
state of the world now you're talking
about like you said you're uh your
vision of the future so
um Ethan said you guys really think
there's there's people born that aren't
going to be like sociopathically greedy
that's that's that's a that seems silly
to me but what do I know
you want you want to live in a society
where sociopaths aren't born anymore
let's do that that sounds like a great
idea to me eradicate sociopathy wait go
back maybe
where is that coming from that's a race
I have no idea what I'm doing I'm trying
to learn his control that's all fun guys
you're right let's you guys here's
here's my platform let's eradicate
sociopathy and personality disorders
we're gonna We're Not Gonna encourage
that no more of that you guys everyone's
gonna be born a perfect healthy human
with perfect parents you're a perfect
family there'll never be any damaged
people it's all good all the time let's
not even worry about it everyone's the
same everyone's great everyone has
Humanity's best interest in their heart
definitely not their own let's go guys
it's perfect Utopia time everybody's
born I just want to live in a Star Trek
bro that's all I'm saying I just want to
live and start everybody I want
to live there too
take place taken like I love Star Trek
but we also need to be able to time
machine yeah we need to be able to
travel
okay congratulations we just secured
person all personality disorders every
child is born with puppies and toys and
futons
and we all have food right nobody will
be hungry because we have food particle
generators that can make any meal you
want replicators hell yeah
thanks guys
uh but yeah I mean the show's been over
so I'm just humoring our uh conversation
yeah thank you Baldur's Gate in a
communism
are you saying you want to socialize
baldor's gate you wouldn't be very in
studios you wouldn't be I think uh wait
a minute aren't they um
where are they from Marion Studios I
don't know if this
is going to make things worse or help
but just say that Ethan I think you're a
wonderful boss very good oh I've had
many bosses you know what I will say
that too since we're uh since we're on
no well thank you for saying that Amy
unfortunately my uh EP wants to
overthrow me and put my head
I can't wait to have your in my
mouth just say thank you Ethan
I did I said Thank you a b and then I
said yeah but then said it too I know I
know we have a we have a wonderful
relationship Eli I know you're a great
boss too thank you we have we have a
wonderful relationship here uh with
everybody in here
[Music]
I'm addressing people who say that
humans aren't uh born greedy some I'm
gonna turn off the chat so you don't get
yeah anymore
disagreeing with chat is now permanently
banned all right bye everyone see you
guys on Monday have a great weekend have
a great weekend love you all
foreign
[Music]